e
than
the
so it looks like we've hit our start
time our uh Bill sponsor is here so why
don't we get started representative Bui
please
so in case it's not obvious will once
again is not here um today he had a
business commitment that he knew of
ahead of time so he had scheduled today
um expecting me to uh to chair this
session um hopefully we won't be staying
here past 5:00 tonight C counting on
that and as a consolation for everyone
um I have a bill to present this
afternoon so I get to go on the other
side of of the table and you can treat
me
accordingly all right uh with that um I
will open the hearing on HB
bill
morning Mr chairman thank
you my name is uh Mark PR representing
Hillsboro 15 which is Manchester Ward 8
this morning I'm uh introducing House
Bill
1051 which
prohibits uh restaurants
from holding wages or making the weight
staff pay a bill of someone who scoots
out without paying
um I've heard this from a couple
different people that they've had to pay
in the
past uh
and I don't think that's really a good
thing to be happening because they have
no control over that if somebody gets up
and walks out they can't tackle them
they you know they can call the police
but they'll be long gone by that time by
the time they get there so I don't think
it's fair for them to have to pay for
somebody that gets up and
and and
um to me this is a pretty simple thing
um from what I
understand uh there's nothing in a law
that says they can but there's nothing
that says they can't so they
do and with that I'll I'll take any
questions and try to answer them to the
best of my knowledge all right thank you
are there questions for the sponsor
representative C
thank you Mr chair uh thank you for
taking my question are you aware of any
other business sector that requires
their emplo or maybe not so much
requires but does have their employees
pay for anybody who steals things or is
this the only one that you're aware of
this business seor the only one that I
know of thank you further questions
representative
suvin just curious how common is this
practice do you know I'm not sure you
know I have a uh some acquaintance
that do this and uh I was told that that
happened matter of fact uh I was eating
dinner one evening and somebody and I
was talking to the waiter and they said
oh yeah I just said somebody just slept
on me and now I'm G to have to pay for
that and I'm like you have to what and
explained it to me and that was a
practice there and then I kind of
started asking around and I've heard of
it at a couple of different people
who've had to do it
representative kahill thank you Mr chair
and thank you representative uh do you
know if the uh restaurant owner might
have insurance to cover such
losses I have no idea I I think I see
someone behind you who might know thank
you
okay further questions representative on
line Thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative PR um so if you have an
employee whose friends come in skip out
on a bill and the employee comes back
and tells you hey you know what these
people just left and unb knowings to the
owner that it was their friends
shouldn't there be some mechanism in
there to hold these people accountable
police but how would he how would he
even find out that they're they're
friends and I I I I understand what
you're saying
but I think if that happened more than
once then the account would be out of
the bag but still breaking the law right
the friends skip out
I'm not going to be happy with my
friends if I have to pay for it that's
for sure cor and what about the business
owner would he follow Mr chairman follow
up would the bu should the business
well so you're talking about one little
piece of a bigger picture right
so if the business owner can have the
police investigate and if they have an
idea that it's their friend I'm sure
they can find out who those people are
thinkk thank you Mr chairman thank you
Mr representative Pro representative C
thank you Mr chairman uh representative
Pro if if I worked at Macy's and I had
friends come in and they stole clothes
and they left would it be reasonable to
expect that I would be paying for their
clothes that they stole no cuz I'd be
calling police on my friends that are
going to jam me up thank you thank
you any further
questions seeing none thank you very
much for your testimony thank you I have
a card uh from Tracy McGraw from the
Department of Labor anticipating that we
may have some questions about the
law good morning my name is Tracy mcra
I'm an attorney in legislative leaon for
the Department of Labor and um I gave
you that card primarily
because of the fact that a law does
exist and it is under
27548 and it is not specific to
restaurant employees it is in general to
all employees that if an employer is
going to deduct anything from an
employee there has to be an
agreement it has to be signed by the
employee there has to be a determination
of whether it's going to be a gradual
deduction another's over a period of
time depending upon the amount or if
it's going to be paid at termination but
the bottom line is is there is a law in
there so there's nothing actually it
would actually be employee theft of by
the employer if they took money from any
of their weights any of their employ
simply to cover a tab that somebody
walked out on um so it's already in the
law and in fact this actual section is
to be put under 1A 1- a as the new
section and it's actually in
already um as to the question with
regards to what does the employer have
as uh recourse if a friend of of a
server walks in and they they either
bail on the check and maybe the server's
involved in it maybe the server's not
involved in it that's a case for
criminal court for Superior Court for uh
restitution for reimbursement for
Recovery uh but that is nothing that's
needed underneath the department of
labor laws all right thank you um are
you aware of
any restaurant employees weight staff
that have made complaint to the
Department of Labor that they have been
had something deducted from their I
asked before I came the answer was no
all right thank you further questions
representative kahill thank you Mr chair
and thank you Miss mcra um I'm
interested in the response you just gave
to that question and I wonder if perhaps
the employees don't know their rights
and that this is actually illegal and
that the Restaurant Association might
include this kind of information what
the rules are as they are providing the
information for tipped tipped wages
tipped employees what their rules and
practices are that uh that you're not
responsible if somebody comes in and
stiffs you I wouldn't argue with that
thank you thank you further questions
representative
Sullivan um thank you for taking my
question thank you Mr chairman um the
um If an employer had a policy that uh
emplo that the weight staff had to pay
for
these um uh checks that were skipped out
on um and they made the employees aware
of that policy upon hire could that be
viewed as an agre I mean you take the
job you live with our policies could
that be viewed as an agreement between
the employer and employee that they
would be stuck with the with the um
Bill if the employer had that policy and
they presented it to an employee um
either after hiring or before hiring if
that employee signed off on that policy
I think the employer would have a better
argument but the bottom line is is that
the statute requires the employee to
agree on any deduction and must sign off
on that
deduction
follow and and so essentially the way
that the um statute reads is that each
time that there's going to be
um a deduction of this nature they would
have to sign off on each one it doesn't
specifically State each time but the
interpretation for the Department of
Labor would be if there is any deduction
to be made from a paycheck normally it
wouldn't be all five at one time so if
there are five different deductions that
need to be made there need to be five
different writings with signatur from
the
employee thank you um if I may follow up
on that if I recall the language of this
statute it is written to be restrictive
in other words the assumption is that an
employer cannot take out of the
employees paycheck except under certain
narrow conditions and to me that's part
of what you're explaining here is that
it's not simply a matter of an employer
writing a policy and saying I'm going to
take stuff from you am I spot on thank
you uh representative kill thank you Mr
chair um when we're talking about
withholding with deducting from wages
are we talking about the tipped minimum
wage that the employer pays or the tips
that they're divied up at the end of the
share I'm not 100% sure that I
understand the question we talking about
here about people who are skipping out
and on this particular bill so if you
could give me a little bit more detail I
can try let's let's just say that uh the
server has had this p a table walk out
this $200 Tab and they they've walked
out uh does when the employer does will
the employer say okay when I give you
your paycheck which sometimes has zero
at the end uh will will I be deducting
it from that or will I the end of this
shift where I take out your tips and say
well you're you owe me for this table
that's that's ski out and I might have
to take out the next time you work too
okay so you're talking about a single
employee whose table walked out and an
employer possibly reducing that
employees tips correct okay same issue
they cannot that's their money that's
their wages and although they're
calculated and they're done differently
in in various establishments those are
still wages and the employer is not
allowed to take them without a signed
document thank you very
much further questions representative
McKenzie uh thank you Mr
chairman if I understand the where we're
going with this legislation is that the
sponsor wants to make it illegal for the
employers to deduct money that's stolen
from uh from a restaurant and so at
least that's what I so we don't want
that we don't want to allow the practice
at all whether they sign or not that
employee should not uh have to pay if
somebody steals something out of the
restaurant and if I understand the
nature of the of the uh what the intent
of the legislation that this is the
intent of the legislation to say no
whether the employee agrees to it or not
I don't know what employee would agree
to it but regardless of that it's the
idea that somebody's stealing something
and the employee is in any way
responsible for that so I think that's
what that's what I understand to the
legislation okay as far as the intent I
I'm I'm assuming that's exactly where it
was going but the law already covers it
so if an employer comes in and says okay
uh Miss Smith your table walked out on
you there's $200 that you now owe me
even if they say you must sign this
document because it was your table they
need to be educated that they don't have
to sign that document it has to be an
agreement not a
forced uh issue and if they don't sign
the document then the employer is not
wages so by touching their wages that
would be a violation of the law which
pretty much goes down what I think the
is further
questions representative d sylvestro
I thank you thank you for taking my
question you said earlier that you had
no reports of this and you're saying um
I think now that an employer might force
or not explain that situation so
therefore an employee would not
necessarily call the Department of Labor
in your opinion because they're afraid
of retaliation so you may not have any
reports I don't want to speculate on
that but the bottom line is is I think
that that is I think that's a fair state
to say but I also think that the key to
all of this is
education what we tell employees we have
all of these placards that are required
to be uh hung at a business and it says
in other applicable laws we don't have
every single employment related law hung
up at a business you'd need an entire
office space for
that so employees need to be educated
and that employers also need to be
educated because it could very well be a
mistaken
expectation of an employee having to pay
for uh a table that walks out so this is
not on one side or the other this is
just purely
education and then the Department of
Labor if they get a claim for it um they
resource did that answer your question
yeah okay would you have a
concern given that you've explained this
would already be
illegal that by itemizing specific cases
where it's illegal
might have uh effects of other cases
where it's also illegal but since we
didn't specifically call it out it might
cause more confusion rather than less is
that part of what you're saying I think
I think that the way that it is written
right now it is interpreted as very
simply the employer cannot touch your
money without your written approval and
agreement with a spelled out document
that says how the money will be taken
from your
pay and leaving it at that leaves It
Wide Open for every other possibility so
that you're not limiting things because
then the bill will end up adding and
adding adding and adding so yes Vice
chair seaworth I I do believe that
leaving it more broad makes it simpler
but if obviously this committee deems
otherwise the Department of Labor will
administer as as you direct thank you
representative
BL this bill to me seems to just uh
clarify what we've already got in
statute for for some people um you know
the a restaurant owner or any any
business owner could uh could just blow
right over this and not not even realize
they're doing something wrong for
starters and the employ and the same
thing going for an employee wouldn't
this be a a good addition to our our
current
law I I'd have to go back to exactly
what I said it's already in there and I
think that I believe it was
representative KC's question about
Macy's so are we going to add dasb that
if it's a retail store and somebody
walks out um having stolen items is that
going to be on the particular um the
particular employee that was working
that section or the person that was
helping
them it's already in the statute that
the employer cannot do this delineating
things it does make it overly
complicated could make it confusing
could make it so that there's more
questions that are
presented but again if the committee do
decides otherwise and to add these
individual exceptions
obviously follow uh would would an
amendment to just to reward this uh
something to the effect no employee
shall be held responsible for theft um
you
know you know put yeah unless wrong but
you know for for any theft I uh I worked
on a beer truck back in the day and you
know we had liquor two and the five
cases of Johnny Walker black when time
took a you know went missing and uh you
know while we were bringing stuff in and
out of the store and uh the the boss did
want to but it was a union job and they
weren't allowed to but um you know that
they they would have if um you know if
that if if they could have uh you know
without without protection uh without
Clarity I think this happens more often
I then I think something to that effect
would clarify the law for even the
simplest of Minds to to understand
I understand what you're saying and if
this committee were to decide that a
clarification needs to go in obviously
the department of labor would be able to
administer that but I do have to
reiterate that it is theft if they do it
any other way than is set into
7548 okay thank you any further
questions representative kahill uh just
to put a finer point on my colleagues
across the way if it was uh other than
other theft other than hand in the till
you know caught in the act definitely
employee responsible would that uh help
us a
bit if an employer has knowledge has a
witness has a credible belief that their
employee is in some way robbing them
whether it's colluding with friends to
walk out on a check or hand in the tail
there are other ways for recourse and
that goes into the various court systems
criminal
law but this covers anything that an
employer could possibly want to deduct
outside of your normal deductions for
insurance and other things that
employees obviously have already written
and approved for those
deductions this covers it as far as the
Department of Labor is deals with these
particular types of cases the rest of it
would obviously have other recourse
thank you any further
questions all right thank you very much
um I do have one other card as uh
anticipating the questions that we have
from uh Mike Summers who's representing
Association good morning Mr Mr chairman
members of the committee thank you uh
for the opportunity to speak to you
today uh again for the record my name is
Mike Summers I'm the president CEO of
the New Hampshire lodging and Restaurant
Association uh I signed in an opposition
frankly because I think this bill is a
solution in search of a problem um as a
department testified they don't get
calls about this um I talk to an awful
lot of people in this industry and I
can't recall the last time I heard of a
case like this um that aside uh one of
the questions earlier was whether or not
uh our association uh does communication
and that kind of Outreach to our members
on this topic and the answer to that
question is yes we do uh we are not
usually focused on this portion of it
but about this part of the statute
because this statute is very
prescriptive you cannot touch any
employees wages they are the property of
the employee you cannot take them unless
they meet one of these very narrow uh
scenarios and I would like to point to
one section which I think the department
essentially referred to which uh for me
is about as clear as you can make it
without making it you know by industry
in an individual in instance which I
think would to one of the comments
earlier it would be just like
wallpapering a room but uh I will read
for you
B2 if I'm reading this correctly for any
purpose on which the employer and
employee mutually agree that does not
Grant financial advantage to the
employer I don't think you how you make
it any clearer than that frankly so
again I go back to I think we're kind of
looking at this is a solution in search
of a problem and I would suggest uh to
the sponsor appreciate the effort
bringing this forward but if he has
heard of instances of this happening we
would highly recommend that uh he
encourage people that he spoken to to
reach out to the department because we
don't stand for it we don't condone it
and we certainly make sure that our
members and and the bulk of the industry
knows about this issue so this is not
new territory the one time the couple of
times that I've heard heard about this
in my 15 plus years in this organization
the only couple of times I'd heard about
when we had business owners who had
moved here from other states where this
is allowed had opened a business and
things had happened etc etc and the
moment we heard about it we made sure to
reach out to them directly and tell them
you cannot do that here um and there are
other parts of the statute that uh there
are similar things like that for example
U I won't open a can of worms I'll stick
to the bill so um so I think with that I
am happy to uh conclude and try answer
any questions you may have all right
thank you
questions representative Granger thank
you so uh question was asked earlier
about uh when it would be taken out of
wages so a lot of employees they get a
paid check so if you're a server you get
a paid check and then you also collect
cash from uh paying customers and then
you would uh pay you would divvy that up
because if they're paying their whole
bill and you know you take your portion
of the tips and you pay take the portion
that's paying for the actual meal you
calculate that up and then you put the
cash in the till uh do you happen to
know if in other states where people do
do this sort of thing when the actual
deduction occurs
normally I can't speak to it because
frankly I've never been involved in it
directly um but I one thing I will
allude to is I know that everyone thinks
that tips are cash these days and I'm
raise show your hand you know show a
hands how many people actually have paid
a bill on a tip recently with
cash
well maybe that's an age thing so um so
setting that aside uh I will say that
most B not most but a a significant
portion of businesses now they don't do
a quote unquote cash out at the end of a
night anymore because the majority of
the tips received by most restaurant
servers now are in the form of credit
card payments so you most of them will
essentially just at the end at the end
of the pay period they will just pay out
all of the tips so my suspicion is if
this is happening in other states it's
probably taken at that point rather than
taken directly out of cash at the end of
a night although I'm certainly sure that
if you know it was in that situation
that could be handled that way thank you
thank you further questions
representative
Kum thank you Mr
chairman would you agree um in talking
about uh RSA
27548 112 or is it 212
112 uh that it would be a disadvantage
to an employer to have somebody steal
from
them
it would be a disadvantage to the
employer but this is about the agreement
between the employer and the employee
and in this instance it would be to the
benefit of the employer and not the
employee because the employer would
essenti employee would essentially be
covering the losses for the business so
I think that the department I don't want
to speak for them I think that's about
as bright a line as you can draw PA
please so if the theft is a disadvantage
would it then become an advantage for
them to be able to recoup the money from
somebody else other than their insurance
company which may for further cause a
penalty to their insurance policy or
other charges so is it then an advantage
because they've recouped their loss from
somebody else well I think that's my
point that if they were have recouped
this money from the employee that
agreement between employee and employer
would be to the advantage of the
employer and therefore not allowed okay
sorry I think I misunderstood what you
said originally I
follow-ups representative mcken thank
you uh so the the person can agree if
they agree to cover the losses of the
employer currently the law allows them
to do that I don't think it
does I I think that is misc
characterization because let me read you
that statement again um which an
employer and employee mutually agree
that does not Grant financial advantage
to the employer and I think any instance
where the employer would retain
wages or earnings of the employee would
be to the detriment of the employee and
the benefit of the employer so I think
and I don't want to speak to the
department but I think that is is a very
bright
love I'm going to guess that uh you know
most of your members are very reputable
businesses they they're interested in
the law they're interested in I hope so
yes and uh but the the sad F fact of the
matter is uh a lot of business aren't
very you know very reputable very uh you
know law-abiding a lot of lot of
businesses fly by the seat of the pants
and uh uh as I go out to eat uh you know
most of the the the weight staff is
usually you know 23 and under you know
young vulnerable gullible uh kids you
know that that don't know uh I like the
idea of clarifying is that a question um
would would you be okay with just
clarifying for the for the Young and not
educated so I have a two-part response
the first part is um I disagree with the
characterization that there are a lot of
disreputable businesses in our industry
I think there are an awful lot of very
good hardworking small mom and pop
businesses in our industry who work very
hard to try to comply with all the rules
and regulations that are laid out before
them I will also say that that is an
awful lot of rules and regulations that
they have to comply with with one of
most heavily regulated industries that
said to your point about clar ification
I think in concept that sounds fantastic
but I think the real issue is there is
not a 22 or a 23 year old that is ever
going to read
27548 and uh you know the department has
already testified that uh you know if
they get a call they certainly educate
folks we work very hard to make sure
that our business owners know what the
rules and regulations are and whenever
we have come in contact with business
and randomly we will get a call from an
employee with a question about something
we make a point if we don't know the
answer we will get them the answer so I
think there are a lot of a lot of
mechanisms of of trying to communicate
what the rules and regulations are but
if if the expectation is that a 22 or 23
or a younger you know less educated
person working in the restaurant
industry working their way through
school or whatever is going to read
effort representative kill thank you Mr
chair thank you SU Tak my question uh
would you believe that uh that I mean I
think you'd acknowledge that not every
restaurant mom and pop or otherwise is a
member of your Association which I think
is a shame because you do so work so
hard to educate them and Us by way of
bringing up this attention to that D12
or whatever it is that I haven't read uh
would you believe that there are that it
does in fact happen and that it
shouldn't happen that people uh get
confronted by the boss well I lost money
today and I'm not going to take it
you're going to give me this money and
or else or you lose your job and you'll
have to go look for another one and it's
not always such a demanding economy up
from the employer side would you believe
that maybe we should do more to educate
perhaps uh maybe that your the other
business owners don't read the statute
either that more education would be
beneficial I would I I'm always for more
education um and to your comment about
what I believe that the happens I'm sure
that there are in some rare instances it
happens um but I don't know that we want
to necessarily uh get tangled up in that
because again I I think it's just
covered in the statute the department
already testified to that uh to your
comment about not all indust uh me you
know businesses in the industry are
members absolutely true we represent
about a third of the industry uh paying
members and and actively participate but
I will also say that as we walk into
those businesses who are not members of
our organization more often than not we
find the materials that we send out to
our members are showing up in their
businesses because our industry is
famous for networking you know we have
five six seven members in an area and
there's 25 restaurants they all talk to
each other they all know each other they
compete with each other they share
things amongst themselves whether it's
food staff Etc um so our reach well if
we can only quantify it by X we know it
is much higher than that um but to the
bottom bottom line of your question yes
we would are normally more open to more
education is always good for everyone
involved follow up so so your materials
are not copywritten or or anything like
that and you might would you might
consider lowering your lowering your fee
for membership so that more people would
join Mr avalani for I don't know if he's
a
member I actually don't recall if he is
you representative Granger uh thank you
the simple question uh insurance
insurance has been brought up a couple
times so is loss from people running out
on their on their tab covered by
insurance
normally not normally and frankly most
businesses wouldn't apply to it because
it would just drive up your insurance
rates um and this is not that common of
An Occurrence that just as a general
rule that people walk out on their tabs
I remember when I was a kid there was
the D and dash scenario right um that
really doesn't happen that that
often thank you representative balone
thank you Mr chairman good to see you
again Mr Summers I am not a member um it
would be improper of me to be a member
and then question you um which is what I
suspected but I want to put you in a
spot so thank you well I I clarified
that um I will say in the light it the
reason that dond Dash has gone away
almost pretty much is the adoption of um
security systems and cameras within
correct restaurants and all all other
areas so I mean it's becoming less and
less of a problem I totally agree with
that statement and
what I believe um totally agree with
that statement um and most restaurants
have cameras right at the front door for
those reasons uh ALS yes that is
absolutely true
yes thank you any further
questions and thank you very much for
your input thank that was the last pink
card I had on this bill uh
representative Kum if you could pass the
blue sheet forward for this bill and um
I see the sponsor of the next bill if
you could make sure your pink card gets
up here that would be
right
is these are the next one that and this
is the so so the this is the sign the
signin sheet for the bill we just heard
uh had no uh signups Beyond those who
testified oh no signups at all um so
with that I will close the hearing on HB
1051 and we'll move directly to the
hearing on HB
bill
hi so I'm representative Eric
Gallagher um representative from uh
conquered Ward six um and I am here to
introduce HB
1072 uh relative to prohibiting
employers from using polygraph
testing
so
um so I bring this bill for
forward uh during a time when we're at
record lows for unemployment and one of
the things when presented with our low
unemployment numbers that people will do
is sometimes they'll say oh
well um the low unemployment numbers
fail to take into account people who
have dropped out of the workforce
entirely so um I've endeavored to
uh take that Counterpoint seriously and
look at addressing some of the reasons
people might drop out of the
workforce um entirely uh one of
which I think is the entire job
application
process that we have and the
um the coercive power that
employers maintain in such a
process um so often times job Seekers
will um when discussing advice with one
another
um what one piece of advice you'll often
hear is oh just lie on your job
application
and the thing is it really shouldn't be
necessary to do that you should be able
to answer the questions in
um in a job interview truthfully without
jeopardizing your employment um so the
bill I originally wanted to file was
something um broader based basically um
regulating the sorts of questions that
can be asked and the types of um answers
that can be provided but um OS never got
back to me uh with or never complet
completed that research request for me
in time but one thing I did find though
that was kind of related to the topic
was apparently um
there's a
federal um employee polygraph protection
act that exists that prevents the use of
um employers from using polygraph tests
commonly as Li detector tests
um and the job app application process
um and so it's it's federal law and it's
got exemptions for state level stuff
which leaves room for states to
craft um their own versions of it and so
I asked OLS if they could draft a state
level version of it for me and they
found actually Vermont has a similar
um law on their books at the state level
that they um largely copied this from um
so yeah basically
um yeah it's basically copied from
Vermont's uh legislation prohibition on
polygraph examinations um although one
thing um so the amendment I passed
around um so one one bit of feedback I
got back from it was um the head of uh
dncr I think the division of natural I
forget the whole acronym something about
natural resources um got in touch with
me um wanting to add an additional
exemption for
um for Rangers in fishing game and
um other sorts
of uh positions like that so given the
existing uh exemptions that are already
in the bill I figured that was fine and
requested that an amendment be drafted
to that effect
um
so yeah to to be clear I I don't think
that job Seekers should lie in job
interviews I just I I do think that um
that employers shouldn't
be putting them in a stressful situation
where um
they're
um apt to screw up somehow just due to
from the um an anxiety about um how to
answer job interview questions
um and
because that's basically what the
function of polygraph tests is it's not
act like they're called lie detector
tests but they're not actually really
good at detecting lies though um you
know there there have been studies
um Paul uh Paul emman a famous
psychologist did studies um showing that
they weren't re um weren't really any
more accurate than like this ancient Tri
practice that um some uncon uncontacted
group had where they'd ask someone to
just hold an egg um and then if it broke
that would um indicate lying and
polygraph tests really aren't that much
more accurate than that
um
so yeah they basically they don't work
they just serve to create anxiety for
job Seekers and therefore should um
be prohibited to prevent
um to to help um help keep job Seekers
from being intimidated during the uh job
application process so let's this bill
and um I'll take questions now thank you
are there any questions representative
Drago thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question I'm curious I see all
the uh the exemptions on the amendment
do what other do you know of other
businesses that are actually
administering polygraph tests I I
honestly don't haven't heard of many
that do
that um well so yeah it the this is
really
um more just
or this is less about any
particular
um any particular case then it is about
the just general chilling effect of the
possibility that that might be one of
the things that might be required um
that it might have on job applicants
um and yeah
just I I think that just knowing that
this wouldn't be something that they'd
have to face would make people more
representative Granger uh thank you uh
question about the egg so I have a
plethora of eggs um but I am constantly
surrounded by Liars because I work in
the state house um how exactly did that
work what do I got to look up in order
so
um well so yeah basically what I I I was
using that as an example of something
that doesn't actually work so I don't I
don't actually recommend that you bring
in eggs um but yeah so for the
comparison
um the so for the comparison between
that and polygraphs um that was
uh famously popularized on the uh TV
show Li toy uh which was in fact based
on real research of the psychologist
Paul Ean
um but yeah basically what polygraphs do
is they just measure the um emotional
excitedness or
agitated um of the person that it's
being administered to and you can be
emotionally excited or agitated for a
lot of other reasons besides lying um
you know Ju Just because you're nervous
or something or other things like that
and you know that's kind of the same
Principle as the egg can also break for
other reasons besides someone lying you
know just because they're
clumsy um so yeah in in in each case
there are examples of um tests that
shouldn't be taken
seriously thank
you any further
questions representative c one thank you
uh Mr chair do you I might have not
heard properly the question that
representative Drago asked but um is
this something that you have experienced
with an employer when you were seeking
or is this something that one of your
constituents brought to you saying that
they feel that this is an issue that
they've experienced what was the impetus
to this um well it's just um yeah again
it's not so much in response to any
particular case of an employer using
polygraph testing as it is to um just
try and to enact some sort of
legislation on the general principle of
um
reducing the imbalance of power in the
um job application process um and it it
is something that people worry about um
you know regard regardless of whether it
actually happens or not so I I think by
passing
this law um you know we could help
instill confidence in more job Seekers
to try to apply for the jobs that
employers are saying they're having such
filling thank you and thank you for
taking my question I as an employer
myself I have had employees come in or
prospective employees drastically
overstate their experience and it was
only after they were hired that I found
out that that they actually did in fact
not know what they were talking about or
what they were doing so I don't
administer a polygraph test I actually
don't know any employers that do but my
question would
be why would it be okay to create a law
to say that I as a business owner cannot
do that to
verify that the person I'm hiring
actually does know the specific skill
set that I want and not just that they
can walk in and be honest and lie on
their application
why do I not have that opportunity if
this bill were to pass well um
so one because it doesn't actually work
and two um
because I I think that a lot of the
problem here is that the motivations are
in place to um for people to like um you
know
if
um you know if employers and the J job
application process had generally
created um more of a culture of being
willing to hire people even when um
they're honest about their shortcomings
and um less likely to um puff themselves
up um then people wouldn't feel as much
of a need to do it any do that sort of
behavior
anymore um so yeah I I I think this is
just one part of um a larger effort
that's needed to change the incentives
involved
here representative
alalani thank you Mr chairman and thank
you representative gag for the questions
today um I see a lot of exemptions in
your Amendment and in the bill are there
any other industries that you think
should not be using polygraphs outside
of the things that the places you
referenced here
mean well I so so I I
personally
um would prefer the list of exemptions
to be kept minimal um the ones that
exist are just for simil it with other
states existing law to make it easier to
administer um since we can then just
base our experience off the experiences
that other states have had with similar
laws um so yeah in in terms of other
exemptions I would look to what other
done any further questions
representative
low thank you for taking my question uh
um you you have your carve outs here
that uh you know the exemptions and uh
you know I I think we could probably go
around this room and everybody everybody
could add one one business or another
that they've known that there lost lost
a lot of money you know to to theft and
uh you know this would this would be
preventing somebody and uh from from
from possibly identifying a a Thief um I
know in my business from time to time
you know my insurance did cover it but I
lost a lot of material and and you know
some tools and and things like that uh
my uh my my late father-in-law 30 years
ago owned two recovery hospitals is is
this a
question um would you
believe uh there were pleas for everyone
in the committee this isn't an
opportunity for us to convince the
people who come to
testify where they might disagree with
us
please restrict this to a question that
you if you want information from the
sponsor try to keep your comments in in
that direction thank you okay um would
you be opposed to having more exemptions
rather than
less
um well all right so I did not oppose
the um DNC
cr's um request to add an exemp um
additional exemption for them because I
saw that as in line with the existing
ones that were already in the bill so I
guess it would really depend on um
whether they're in line with the
existing ones in the bill or
not thank you any further
questions thank you very much for your
testimony thank you next up and I I
don't want to mispronounce your name so
I'll let you say it but from the New
Hampshire Association of chiefs of
police uh 3 minutes of testimony you
didn't sign in either for or against
morning I'm sorry so good morning uh my
name is Charles rage I'm the chief of
the Hinsdale police dep department and
um the reason that we didn't sign for or
opposed is because um we believe that
this bill is proposed has uh and some
areas of concern for us for some of our
employees who aren't necessarily sworn
police Personnel um overall I have a lot
of experience working with polygraphs
I'm not a polygrapher um but there are
specific tool for a specific purpose um
they're very good at uh determining
whether or not someone's accurate on
their application on the background
other things it's uh no different than
if you have a Carpenter and he's got a
saw and he makes precise cuts when he's
building a house or mechanic that needs
a wrench to get into a certain piece of
a car it's uh it's the same thing and uh
we believe that it's important to give
our employees all the tools they need to
do a good job to hire the best employees
possible uh the polygraph is important
because it's a double check of a
background process um and I'm sure that
that translates into uh many fields that
are outside of law enforcement probably
medical uh Insurance banking um anything
in the finance world I have witnessed uh
many polygraphs in my career I've been
the subject of two of them I've
witnessed employees I've witnessed them
with um sometimes as suspects and crimes
so I I can say with uh with a degree of
certainty that it that depends on the
operator if you have a polygrapher who's
very good with us using his tool um
that's the same as bringing your car to
a reliable mechanic you want to make
sure that it's it's operating properly
and I can say through 20 years of
experience that I know that it works and
it works very well um in law enforcement
we do have very uh a very large group of
people who aren't necessarily sworn
officers you have uh Corrections guards
um evidence technicians I mean imagine
you have somebody in an Evidence room
they're handling narcotics money firearm
uh dispatchers they know everything
about people they have their social
security numbers their driver's license
their mother's made a name um so they're
handling uh very sensitive information
and other things too like social workers
you know they we're hiring social
workers now we spent a lot of time and
energy the last four years learning how
to deescalate situations how to uh help
get out involved in the community and
undercut problems before they start and
all these people they're uh they're
holding important positions that are
responsible to the community and they're
responsible to the department and to the
public in general and uh I think that I
speak on behalf of the association when
I say that we want to make sure that we
provide the public with the best public
servant we can give you and the
polygraph is a good way of doing that
and the the bill was written doesn't
cover our non-sworn
Personnel thank you for your testimony
um I have a question the sponsor
indicated um that there's Prohibition in
federal law are you familiar with the
scope of the federal law as it applies
to this I'm not I'm a specialist in law
enforcement and for us we're covered all
right thanks any further
questions representative B Lon thank you
Mr chairman thank you Chief ratash um
the you mentioned suspect questioning
for polygraph if this bill as written
and with the amendment would that you
would be able to do that anymore would
you
believe I'm not sure I would want to
Prov provide that to uh to our attorneys
and have them Overlook that I'm not I'm
not certain that we would still be
allowed to do that under this not
confident thank you Mr chairman further
questions seeing none thank you very
much for your testimony thank you sir
the final card I have on this bill is
Kate Horan from the New Hampshire
Association of counties um speaking for
two minutes in opposition to the bill
and has some written testimony for us
thank you Vice chair seaworth my name is
Kate Horan I represent the New Hampshire
Association of counties which is all of
your elected and appointed officials uh
at County government level I'm here
today to speak on behalf of the county
superintendents as the chief mentioned
correctional officers are not sworn law
enforcement and therefore do not would
not fall under the exemptions that are
listed in this bill polygraphs are an
important part of hiring correctional
officers at the County uh Correctional
facilities and we would want to ensure
that this bill was amended to include
them or that the bill not moveed forward
uh I'm happy to take any questions uh
but I'll conclude my testimony all right
thank you very much are there
questions I don't see any so thank you
again um as I said that was the final
pink card that I had so if there's no
one else who wishes to speak on that
representative kokum if you could pass
and our next hearing will be scheduled
at 11:00 so the um committee will be in
recess until that time uh we have one
additional uh sign in on the blue sheet
in opposition to the bill so with that I
will close the hearing on HP HB
1072 and we are in recess until 11:
thank
you
e
it looks like we're at 11 o'clock um are
sponsors and if you could pass the pink
card
forward
good morning thank you very much good
great so I will open the public hearing
on
HB
1110 and ask the sponsor to introduce
his
bill good morning Mr chairman members of
the Labor's commit committee my name is
representative Tim MCU I represent marac
hillsbrook County 12 and I'm here to
talk to you today about fairness in the
labor market leveling the playing field
asking our employers with employees more
than 25 to use the federal free E verify
system to make sure everyone has access
to the same types of
employment this this bill simply does
that if you have more than 25 employees
that ask you in addition to filling out
the I9 form to validate the perspect
itive
employees work eligibility using the E
verify system so I imagine there's a lot
of folks here that are familiar with e
verify I've heard about it over the
years excuse me there's now I think my
written testimony said 22 but a few more
states have enacted it first of the year
so we're up to about 25 states that use
e verify in some form or
another uh and the reason they do so is
because e verify has a couple
differences uh between verify in the I9
form so they still have to fill out the
I9 form uh you know look at the social
security card but with the I9 you don't
actually have to have a picture ID to
get employment you need a social
security number right to be lawfully
employed in the United States takes
about seven days or so to get it uh you
can go through the ever verify process
without a social security number while
you're while you're waiting for it and
there's like I I think it's 3 weeks
specifically uh to get it usually takes
about 7 days to get it in the mail uh so
this doesn't preclude someone from
applying for a job even being offered uh
the job um without a social security
card but what it does do is it allows
people who are competing for jobs with
potential ineligible employer employees
to compete on the same level so you have
someone who has all their paperwork in
order and they're competing for a job
against other folks who may not and the
employer potentially and often does uh
pay a lower wage for those jobs and
that's just not fair for people who've
done it the right way who have a Social
Security and who are eligible to be
employed so that's basically what this
bill does in in a nutshell it's a way to
make it easier for employers to obtain
accurate employment eligibility
information using ever verify years ago
you may have heard uh well verify is not
always accurate it's those problems that
were widely publicized about five six
years ago have long since been fixed
it's easy to get into easy to use and
it's free um for the
employer so I think this initiative is a
significant step forward to ensuring
fair and legal and efficient employment
in our states doesn't change the
recordkeeping requirements that already
exist I'm sure you all are familiar you
have to do the I9 form you have to keep
copies of the the paperwork and the
document um but it will help employers
potentially avoid those big fines from
250 to $2,500 those aren't the exact
numbers it's like two 273 and there some
very odd numbers but about 250 to two to
$2,500 uh for inaccurate I9 this takes
that right out of the picture um so on
an I9 form of course is mandatory
currently e verify is voluntary uh I9
you can actually do without a social
security number and with eify you have
to have a Social Security number
eventually to complete to close that
case uh So within about 3 weeks of
opening it you have to have that and you
need to have a uh photo identity uh
document from the typical uh list B is
everyone familiar with the the different
columns ABC I think everyone on labor
knows about that
um so this is simply a streamlined way
uh streamlined way to verify employment
eligibility for small employers who
don't have um well slightly you know
bigger than 25 employers that don't have
HR departments or the ability to do that
sort of thing the government provides
this free service for that uh and and it
creates a very Level Playing Field
um I'll take any questions if you have
any on on the background of e verifier
how we got here all right thank you for
your testimony I do have a a question
clarification um from what you said you
talked about that it doesn't change the
recordkeeping requirements and we we
heard that we've heard this bill a
number of times so I've heard that
before that ever verify doesn't apply
additional laws it's a electronic way of
of
tracking eligibility for employment but
your testimony today said that in fact
fact an employer that either is required
or elects to use e
verify might reject some applicants who
would be eligible without ever verify
but under ever verify they're not is
that what I heard you saying so if I
understand you're correctly Mr chairman
and thanks for bringing that up
um e verify makes what they already do
more reliable and more accurate it do
does I'm not I think I understood your
question um and it does sound like you
did and it was it was probably my
misinterpretation of what you were
saying that
there might be additional requirements
for ever verify users and I was that I
mean sure you could look at it and say
this is an additional requirement
because if you have more than 25
employees you have to log in and and do
a quick check so there's some keystrokes
on a computer um that that's correct
then the benefit is all your prospective
employees are viewed equally with equal
status and you know that the documents
being submitted to satisfy the federal
federally required employment
eligibility check are valid right it's
got It's it's that check for you so it
really protects both parties the
employer and the employee right the
employee doesn't have to settle for a
lower wage because there are other
applicants who are willing to take a Cut
Rate pay because they may not have they
check does that make
sense thank
questions representative kahill thank
you Mr chair and thank you
representative so if I understand this
correctly any employer may now
voluntarily use this
system 100% correct yeah th this bill
simply requires it for
25 employees or more follow up uh why
why the 25 number of threshold if um why
wouldn't you require for
all that's that's a good question um so
i' I'd love for it to be more other
states have 50 other Stakes have made it
mandatory for all public employees
um it it seems that the threshold or the
tolerance level is at about 25 or 50
with legislation that's passed around
the country and in talking to some of
the really small employers uh Farm Stand
that has uh you know some seasonal
increase to help pick pumpkins grapes
apples you know the crops that we have
in New Hampshire corn whatever um
that they would rather be able to
they're always under 25 and they thought
that for the volume of employees that
they have come through for a couple days
at a time that it would just be too much
hassle for them so it it seemed like 25
was a good starting point certainly open
to discuss the number make it 50 make it
zero depending on the will of the
committee the committee's bill so the
people with the farm stands don't have a
smartphone that they could quickly
use uh you know I didn't pull all the
people with the Farm Stand so I'll I'll
talk about the the couple that I'm
pretty familiar with and shop at myself
in the local nashwa maram Hollis kind of
area um they do and they're very careful
actually uh about checking their the
documentation their of their workers
they've been asked and queried in the
past by you know passers by that they
they weren't sure who's who's asking why
are you asking who my employees are uh
you know they've had run-ins with uh
legal folks before so they're very
careful to dot their eyes and cross
their tees and they don't object um but
but the issue I think is is making sure
that it's it's passable and that the
majority of the small business with
seasonal or migrant workers uh are are
satisfied so 25 seemed to be about the
right spot to start thank you further
questions seeing none thank you very
much oh you do have a question oh you do
I'm all right thank you again thank you
ladies and gentlemen for your time um
next up I'd like to call Devon chaffy
from the ACLU New Hampshire in
opposition to the bill with two minutes
of
um I will ask you and if if you need to
wait till you're done please fill out
separate cards or do I already have I
have this is your cardr okay so th
Christine
Wellington um also in opposition to the
you good morning everybody I'm Christine
Wellington I'm um a resident of Derry
and I'm a member of the New Hampshire
immigrants rights task force last night
I sent to each one of you or emailed to
each one of you a copy of our opposition
letter um and thank you for the
opportunity for us to uh speak to you
today
um as as uh representative MCU mentioned
um and and folks on the committee
mentioned uh e verify is already
available to employeers who want to use
it um it's not mandatory in this state
um the vast majority of the states have
not seen fit to mandate their employers
to engage in eify even in some of the
states that um do have e verify mandates
it's only for public employees and not
for private employers which I think is
also an important Point um ever verify
was launched almost 30 years ago and yet
it still has this very poor
participation rate of about 12% of
employers within the United States use
it even in states where e verify is
mandated to private employers many are
scoff laws and don't participate for a
variety of reasons um our primary
concern is uh the immigrants rights
network is the effect it would have on
folks who are perceived to be
non-citizens or actually are
non-citizens um representative MCU
mentioned that um um this would help uh
eligible uh folks from being hired
rather than ineligible people that
suggests that there's a pre-screening
that would go on and there isn't an
employer can't um ask for the I9
documents that we uh all employers must
request or do an E verify till an
employment decision has been made in
fact um one of the outcomes of the ever
verify program has been an increase in
employment discrimination based on
um nationality and the US Department of
Justice has put out guidance for folks
that use ever verify because of the
concerns pre-screening selective um uh
interviewing of folks that you think
won't ever that are US citizens so you
don't have to go through it um failure
to tell um an employee that they uh came
back as ineligible and and giving them
the chance to challenge that ineligible
eligibility even today um with the the
better um uh they've improved the error
rate of of um Mis uh misapplication of
of
eligibility in 2022 which is the latest
year that I could find for numbers
almost 60,000 actually eligible folks
were turned down because of an Ever
verify um eror so that's of a primary
concern to us and um last lastly uh this
doesn't seem to be consistent with um
New Hampshire's uh approach toward its
business and to let employers decide
what's best for them small businesses
would probably be at greatest risk
because you do need um HR help to get
these um processes done correctly so um
thank you I I'll yield to my
colleague thank you as jel Bonet legal
director of the ACLU of New Hampshire
and just a few additional points uh
beond what attorney Wellington said um I
I did want to just flag for the
committee that there is actually a
pretty rich history of this committee
considering uh similar versions of this
bill uh and rejecting it on a bar
bipartisan basis for many of the reasons
that attorney Wellington just presented
so I did want just want to flag that for
the committee uh it it it I can read
those two those three bills it's uh 2012
HB 1620 2015 HB 267 and 2022 hb1 24 just
just two years ago and Not only was it
because of the inaccuracy concerns that
would have been raised but also because
of the business concerns that have been
raised the fact that what this bill does
um whether you agree or not with the
underlying rationale is it imposes a
burden a regulation on business at the
end of the day some businesses may think
that that's fine um including some in
this room other businesses may not for
for various reasons but this does add a
burden and in addition to the eror rate
though it has been improved it still
does exist and I think a single person
that improperly loses out on a job
because of this is one too many and so
for those reasons uh we as well would
ask that the committee reject this Bill
thank
you are there questions representative
bruy thank you Mr chairman Joe I didn't
get your last name oh I'm sorry it's a
Binet a be and boy I SS o NN e tte it's
like a Mississippi so lot of lot of
double continence I'm the legal director
at the ACLU of New Hampshire thank you
my my boss Devon cha filled out the card
only because I was in a different
hearing
so other
questions representative balani thank
you Mr chairman uh and thank you Mr
biset um the question I have is once you
start ever
verify um is it mandatory to continue
that process so business can't opt out
once they're
in um
they can opt out when it's completely
voluntary it's an employer decision so
if it became too burdensome or they lost
their HR person they could they could
stop thank you thank you Mr
chairman other
questions representative
suvin could you give some um more detail
about the U the error rate what sorts of
Errors uh take place uh
currently well you want me to go on oh
that's so this this is a system that
relies on what the employer puts in and
what the records uh um in they ever
verify queries both the Social Security
Administration and USCIS um the
immigration Service uh for for uh
eligibility to work um so input by the
employer can be problematic and if
there's um records that are uh have uh
erroneous information on them th those
can be problematic so that that those
could be two sources of a mismatch
coming back uh that where an eligible
employee is deemed ineligible maybe a uh
a similar name Etc so um right now
there's a pretty low error rate I
believe it was about
1% um but of those 12% of us employers
that use it that still translated in 20
22 to almost
60,000 actual eligible employees that
were initially and maybe permanently um
um deemed a mismatch because one of the
other problems that Strays into
disperate treatment and discriminatory
treatment is many of the employeers fail
to tell that prospective employee that
they they were a mismatch they just say
we can't hire you um and so that person
never realizes that and therefore never
has an opportunity to to grieve that and
to the the uh e verify system and and to
to fix that problem yeah and I would
just add on to that I think it's true
that the error rate is low relative to
the number of queries that have been
raised it is high relative to the number
of lives impacted
58,000 uh individuals as reflected in
footnote 8 of Our Testimony real people
just trying to work who can't work
because of this or may or may have their
ability to work hinder it I should say
as a result of
this representative kahill thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question uh is it also possible that
there may be sort of special characters
in a person's name that aren't entered
into the system either by the person
with the Farm Stand and the and the and
the smartphone like is there an out can
anybody find the umla on their
smartphone yes that there's those are
exactly some of the problems or customs
in other countries whether your your
family name comes first or last as it
does here or whether you have three or
four family names and maybe in um your
home country your mother's name would
become lost uh but you know in in the US
we generally use or we used to I guess I
should say um one's father's name would
would come last so there's this's
confusion um in th in those ways and
llots and things like that certainly
have caused problems just
honest errors but errors
nonetheless thank you would you believe
that my wife from Nigeria has seven
names I would I did practice immigration
law for a while so I uh I'm familiar
with folks that have very different
styles of identifying um who they are
and their family lines Etc thank
you further
questions seeing none thank you very
much for your testimony thank
you
and did you have separate testimony or
so all right thank you very much I have
one final card on this bill Steve Dupri
um speaking for himself for three
bill morning Mr chairman members of the
committee my name is Steve dupry I live
in conquered I'm originally from Conway
I had the honor of serving in this body
50 years ago and back then I figured out
my hourly rate was about 27 cents an
hour you guys meet a lot more I like to
kiddingly say you're worth every penny
but seriously thank you for your service
uh I have no stake in this I uh have no
Ox toore I just thought it would be
useful to hear from an employer by way
of background uh we are the largest
employer of new Americans those are
citizens or excuse me refugees who are
given uh admission to this country
because they um a humanitarian crisis
South Sudan is a great example so
they're here legally they come as uh
non-citizens they're given an
opportunity to work uh we started the
largest new American job training
program in this state and funded it very
extensively they are frankly some of our
very best employees who've been with us
a long time many of them are illiterate
um many don't know their birthday you'd
be surprised out of my 300 Associates
how many have a January 1 birthday
because that's what's assigned to them I
use ever verify and I and I thought I
would just give you our
perspective the error rate when it
started was high the error rate now is
less than 2% the largest source of
errors in our experience which is
consistent with what the research shows
is that there's incorrect information
entered by the HR department off the
I9 uh or there's been a change in a name
spelling because people have many
different name spellings uh from where
they've come from and remember a good
portion of our Associates are when they
first start with us are illiterate or
there's been a change in their
immigration status what the reason we
use it is there are a large number of
people who are able to obtain social
security cards that are false and I9
that look okay what the eify does and
you are talking to somebody who is not
good with computers but my HR department
made me try it is that it's less than a
two-minute process it is not hard
technologically but when that
certificate gets printed out or they you
print the the approval and you put that
in that file if it turns out
subsequently that you were misled by a
prospective employee you the employer
are protected from liability and that's
why we do it um I'm not not here to
debate whether folks who aren't
documented should work or not the
federal law says it's against the law
for us to hire people who are not
eligible what it does for an employer is
it gives you that Shield it's not hard
to do
technologically uh the error rate used
to be bad and we were an early adopter
uh it's much less now and it's usually
one of those two things a name
misspelling which as you can imagine
with somebody who's an illiterate news
citizen it's very important you actually
check the name against their documents
that allowed them to come into this
country uh there's a now pre-check
system to make sure you don't push that
button and it gives us that
security does it deny those people who
there is a false what I'll call a false
positive it does but here's what else is
going on and it happens in New Hampshire
and it happens nationally there are a
lot of people who get employed who can't
get ever verified because they do not
under our federal laws have the right to
work here yet there are people who will
hire them and they end up hiring them at
lower wages because people want to work
that's understandable they're here they
want to work and it's easy for somebody
who wants to cheat the system to say I'm
not going to pay you minimum wage or I'm
going to withhold your pay and that
person because they don't have legal
status to work gets punished for that is
that going on you bet it is I think some
of you remember about a decade ago one
of the larger national food chains was
caught with thousands of employees it's
an easy trick if you want to find cheap
labor and don't want to pay much you
just skirt this system if it were me I
would say every employer should do it
it's not that hard to do I am not a
computer genius but if I can do it i'
say that's a baseline I again I'm I'm
not hired by anybody I'm not part of the
Bia I'm not part of any association I
have lots of good friends on the other
side I think I'm a pretty strong
supporter of civil liberties but I just
it's an easy protection to make sure
that workers aren't exploited who don't
have the right yet to work here and at
the same time giving a shield to
employers it's worked very well for us
it is not burdensome and I just thought
I'd make sure I offered that testimony
because I know you debate this issue
often all right thank you very much I do
have a question you uh testified that
you initially adopted this voluntarily
have you found found um that some of the
contracts that you engage in require it
like a federal contract absolutely yeah
we provide janitorial services in some
federal and state uh buildings where
we're required to pass a higher security
level and we are required if we work I
I'm not the HR department with 300
Associates I'm just a reformed lawyer um
but uh in some of our federal contracts
we are absolutely required to all right
thank you further questions
uh representative
love thank you for your testimony thank
you Mr chair uh you mentioned a 2% false
positive do you know if there's a a way
to for a potential employee to uh to
straighten that mess out there is but
I'm going to In fairness it's very
burdensome okay um I I'll be honest if
you have somebody here who doesn't
English isn't their first language
they're trying to navigate uh being in
this country um it is difficult to do
and uh as noted by a previous speaker I
am sure there are some employers who
once they get that false positive back
maybe don't report that in our case we
are so grateful to have anybody who
wants to work and show up if we get a
false one we try and work through it and
usually get them resolved does that take
yes other questions was there a hand
over here all right representative
ccum thank you thank you very much Mr
chair and thank you for that answer can
I just follow up on one thing are you
allowed to still hire them while you
fixing that process or is that
preventing you from hiring them we
don't we we'd rather be safe than sorry
I mean we're we're large enough that we
get lots of audits from lots of
departments and we are on the side of
safety you can usually resolve it in a
in a fairly short time but you have to
take the effort follow follow but you
you're not sure if you are allowed I
can't remember I I just can't that's so
far beyond my pay
grade I have very minimal competencies
I'm the Vana White of my organization
which tells you we're probably in
trouble was there a question over
here no uh representative Al thank you
Mr chairman good to see you again Mr
dpri thank you
sir so you use you adopted EFI a long
time ago yeah um you've worked through
some false positives um um on those
false positives would they have passed
the I9 Check Yes some do thank you thank
you Mr chairman not all but some do and
our goal is just to make sure that
everybody who works we're protected from
any liability and like I say I do know I
am sure I know in the hospitality
industry there are people who are hired
who aren't eligible to work and then
they are frankly uh they're not treated
fairly other question
seeing none thank you again for your Tes
thank you appreciate your service good
luck everyone so um as I said that was
the last pink card that I had if there
are no more um people wishing to
tesy representative if you could
find the blue sheet for this bill and
pass it
forward and I thought I saw
online
that's all
you so I was um asked
to uh get a copy of the online signin
because as most of us probably realize
now a lot more people go on to the
website to indicate their opposition or
support of a bill than actually come
here and sign the blue sheet these days
uh one caveat uh with the numbers on
that is that when there is online
testimony for a bill that remains open
um until midnight so these will not be
the final numbers this will be what we
had uh whenever we printed them out so
there were only two signin on the blue
sheet uh one of them was uh one of our
speakers the other one uh signed in in
opposition to the bill and then let me
can does this there it is it's at the
top so signing in online we had two in
support and 109 in
opposition so with that I will close the
hb110 and that covers us through
lunchtime we will res uh recess until
bill
that we
discussed
it's
I and one of the
things you can't just in and out you
I
all right we'll open the hearing on uh
Bill
1201 1:00 uh calling representative
Testimony thank you Mr chairman uh for
again for the record my name is
representative Brian seaworth I
represent the town of Pembrook and I'm
here today to introduce my bill HB
121 um this is a bill that's been
nagging at me for years now and I
finally decided this was the year to put
it in I I think fixing this RSA is
important and um it's a good time to to
do it I also put it in because I I think
this is an easy bill um I may not have
gotten the language perfect but I really
think the people on this committee are
the right ones to um make sure that we
get this policy
right uh I'll go a little bit into some
of the background of uh where this came
from uh hopefully not get too into the
weeds but first uh so what is this RSA
this is a section of law that deals with
what happens when an employee dies while
working and is owed money by the
employer and the law says that under
certain conditions the employer May pay
out that owed money directly to the air
of the deceased employee without going
through probate and to kind of simplify
uh there are three conditions one is
it's May it's a may be paid so if there
are reasons that the two parties think
it it should go through probate they're
not required to pay
directly number
two um if the estate is already in
Probate for other reasons then you must
go through that process number three the
amount has to be $300 or less
and when I've explained what I'm doing
to people that's usually where I get the
funny look cuz that it just doesn't make
sense it's such a small amount of money
that you wonder well why cap it there
and the answer is also
simple this law uh it dates back to the
30s um it was last changed in
1963 and since 1963 the dollar has lost
north of 90% of its value so
$300 in 63 in1 1963 is worth and and my
guess was about 10 times that today so
that's the change that I made um part of
what I did is I wanted to be
conservative
with um mirroring the intent of the law
as it stood in 1963 not make some
unintended changes so I tried to work on
how I got that
number um so let me just go back through
how this bill came to us um the RSA is
actually what's in the bill is the full
RSA this isn't there isn't other
relevant sections that are outside of
that um it was part of a process uh
about five years ago now when we
established a legislative study
committee to look at labor laws that
were
archaic and then chairman
Sullivan uh came up with some excellent
ideas that limited the scope we focused
on wage and hour and protective
legislation and we focused on items that
the Department of Labor could identify
as problematic and brought to
us this was one of those sections that
the Department of Labor flag
the reason that they said they flagged
it is that it's one of those areas where
they got a lot of questions people call
up and you can see the language that's
here it's a it's a bit esoteric and
people say I don't understand what I'm
looking at could you help me so that's
why they brought it to us in that
committee as we worked on it one of the
issues is some of these this language
like letters
testamentary uh or of
administration
um the the pendency of probate
proceedings these are legal terms of Art
and we were concerned that so if you
don't know probate this is very
confusing if you do know what it means
it's very precise and we didn't want to
go paraphrasing precise legal terms and
potentially creating Fallout but we did
immediately focus on this 300 $100
number at the time though we couldn't
really agree on what the right number
was so the suggestion from that
committee back when was that this should
be
amended but we don't know what to um so
the 3,000 as I said it's easy enough you
can find a lot of calculators online
that you can say what is
1963 uh $300 in 1963 worth in today's
dollars and it uses the inflation number
it comes up around 10 I also looked at
wages and I sent some documents around
that I had used in case you want to kind
of see where I was coming from that
again it was kind of an order of
magnitude between what people were paid
for a similar job in 63 as today the
other thing I looked at is what
$3,000 is in terms of the average wage
and I sent that in the email mail if if
it's the mean wage it's
about um 2 and 1 half weeks of pay will
make $3,000 at the median wage it's more
like three weeks so this all the $3,000
feels kind of right to me in that it's
more than a bi-weekly paycheck for most
people the other thing that I wanted to
point out is I did make some change to
the uh last
sentence which basically was saying that
if there is no um will or probate that
specifies who the heir is then you use
New Hampshire law to figure it out and
so I went to OS and said can't we just
point people to the New Hampshire law
instead of trying to describe it and
they came back with this um last line
and bold which makes sense to
me um so with that I think I've talked
enough I'd be happy to answer questions
on
this representative biry thank you Mr
chairman um does this $3,000 count like
unpaid vacation and sick time and uh any
so my understanding and and one issue is
I would have a hard time answering how
this law is interpreted today and that's
the key is that at least my goal here
was not to change the interpretation of
the law but to update it so that it
applies as intended as I read it it's
any money that the employer owes the
employee through employment
not restricted to some categories but
not others one of the issues we have
here is now that it's down to
$300 I'd imagine there isn't a lot of
current um experience as to what happens
and where people you know try to figure
this out so that's one of the when we
move it back up to a a relevant number
we might see
people things that haven't happened in
many years
now coming to the four again my belief
is that um though it would cover any
money due the
employee oh yeah thank you Mr chairman
you think $3,000 is enough if you have
three weeks pay coming 3 weeks vacation
coming uh four unused sick days that
could go way over
$3,000 thank you for that question and
and I agree and as I said part of what I
was trying to do
was um think about all the opinions that
we had when we discussed this in in the
committee um I personally would be happy
going higher there was a member of the
committee that felt you know you could
have potentially some very big if
somebody's on commission and is owed a
very large commission the the money
could get substantial and there was some
concern about well is there a number
that that's too high and you want to
force it through probate because of the
complexity um and that's why I don't
think this is a partisan bill I don't
think this is a political bill but I do
think this will be a a good bill to
discuss in committee and try to figure
this out uh one suggestion that another
member of the committee who's not here
made to me um that might make sense is
rather than set a new dollar amount
which will start to become obsolete as
soon as we get some new inflation is
maybe you do tie it to pay periods that
you know that
it's
a a two- week pay or half the monthly
pay or something and and using either an
average or his suggestion was actually
look at the workers you know whatever
your your monthly amount is you set the
limit according to that so these are
options that
I think you've identified a good point
and there might be some good ways to
solve it okay quick followup Yeah final
final followup thanks if if we had a cap
say 3,000 and there's money left over we
could use a 3,000 payable right away and
arrest go into probate with everything
else interesting question and again um I
would probably defer to a lawyer or
someone who knows how this was handled
cuz I I could could interpret in either
way that you can pay up to 3,000 and
withhold a less or you could read this
to say if it's more than
3,000 all of it has to go through
probate and I I can't answer how the
existing law would be
interpreted
okay one final thought one final
followup yeah well only because if it's
a young person they may not have enough
money put aside for a funeral and all
that stuff so they'll need this money up
front exactly and I I think that's why
passing a good version of this bill
however we decide to mend it is
important because when a family loses a
primary bread winner they're going to
need
money now not in six nine months when
everything gets worked out with the
lawyers thank
you representative kill thank you Mr
chair and thank you representative for
taking my question um I don't see a
linkage to 275 colon
43 but I think perhaps the department
could clarify this disposition of of
wages might be pursuant to the policy
and practice of the
employer um could be maybe um but uh I'm
not I'm not I'm not familiar with
probate but I I do know that my my uncle
passed away and I believe they had a
joint account everything was frozen and
there was no money at all that my aunt
could access to to do anything so I
don't it's it's different from the old
days when you would when the wife would
go down to the mill and pick up the pay
envelope whether he was dead or alive
and we don't we don't quite do that
these days you just the boss would just
hand it over to you in the event of the
untimely death but uh interesting Bill
and thank you for bringing it and uh yes
I know you would believe
thank you and I I do um I have thought
about that that the world has changed a
lot with direct deposit and and the way
money is transferred and there may be a
lot this bill might have a much smaller
scope than it did 60 years ago um
but I I think if there are some cases
where a family can get money sooner
rather than later I'd like to be able to
help them do it
thank
you um any further questions for uh
um representative
Sullivan um I'm I'm hoping that perhaps
the uh the Department of Labor can help
us out with how this is being
interpreted now because uh as you just
said I suspect the um with direct
deposit that that just sort of goes you
know on automatic pilot and I would
imagine that in the today's world um if
somebody's on direct deposit that will
be deposited into their account and if
it's a joint
account um but at any rate maybe the
department can give us some current uh
practice on
this I think we can ask um M mcra to
come up
representative seaworth uh for
question representative kill yeah thank
you sir uh I wonder if if even the
direct direct deposit would the employer
upon noticing knowing of the death would
he would everything freeze and he
wouldn't make the
payment I think that's an excellent
question and I don't know the answer to
thank
you um given the discussion here maybe
getting rid
of not an excess of but just a in the
event of a death and of an employee
wages due by an employer May upon proper
demand be paid maybe we get rid of the
dollar
amount I am I think that's a great
discussion to have the
question that I would bring forth from
the members of that legislative
committee is so what if that due money
is a huge commission you you got a
million dollars on a sales contract
that's due is there a risk
with allowing you know maybe my ex-wife
and two girlfriends all show up asking
for that money is there is there some
protection that needs to be in law or is
it sufficient to say you know let people
deal with it on a case-by Case basis I
don't know I think I look to the
committee to help
me to get this
right any further questions for
representa C
Ru thank you for your testimony thank
you very
us
good
afternoon okay I'm back on good
afternoon my my name is Tracy mcra I'm a
uh one of the attorneys and legislative
leaz on for the Department of Labor and
I am here to answer any questions that
you may have on this particular
Bill if you want to direct them or I can
start whatever is up to you
representative
yes I'm on um the um I guess just
looking for any information you can
provide on how this is currently being
administered um uh whether the $300 is
um uh paid out as as the minimum amount
and the rest withheld or you know
exactly how does this work
today I do not actually have a specific
answer to that question I can certainly
find out and pass around that
information to the committee once I do
uh to the best of my knowledge this is
not a large issue that comes up at the
Department of Labor so it's probably
handled at the employer level but I
would prefer to check with our
Inspection Division and our wage and
hour Division and see if they've gotten
any kind of issues that come in they're
the ones who do the inspections going in
and finding out if the employers are
complying um the I I'm not an estate
lawyer for good reason um but there are
rules underneath the estate probate and
succession as to what monies can be paid
where they can be paid the biggest
concern that we discussed at the
department on this particular uh issue
is if the money is given to the wrong
person in other words contrary to
5611 or any other way it's a possibility
that an employer could end up having to
pay
again even though there's actually part
two of this statute that specifically
says that uh a release and discharge
should be provided for the amount paid
so if in this particular case let's say
the person was owed
$5,000 and the employer paid $3,000
pursuant to
5611 there could be a release and
discharge that's uh filed for just that
$33,000 it doesn't mean even based on
the current statute doesn't mean that
the employee will not get another Penny
or the deceased will not get another
Penny it just means that that amount has
been paid and has been satisfied but
there were concerns from my colleagues
at the department of if something was
direction Fallout representative um I
happen to call up um RSC uh
5611 and I would suggest that if you are
not an estate lawyer and you're trying
to follow
5611 you're going to have a problem so
employers trying to figure out who to
give the money to are going to have a
problem I would agree that a state law
is a very specialized practice um but
because this is actually listed
underneath the protective legislation
and it's under
275 uh they can come to the Department
of Labor and there can be some direction
given in that respect we would basically
have to administer the statute as it is
at $300 with the tweaks that um
representative seaworth had suggested
even we would still have to uh deal with
that if it became an issue at the
department whether it's at a hearing or
just an administrative
order so that would assist the employer
saying any further questions
representative Koo Mr chair and thank
you Mr mcra so would you clarify the the
one about the with the vacation and all
the other things be included or would be
pursuant to the policy and practice of
the employer so under 27543 you're
looking at payment of wages wages
underneath that statute
incorporates um paid time off vacation
time sick time and any time that's
actually owed to the employer the
employee excuse me so if the way I I
read this bill the way I interpret this
bill if the amount of vacation time sick
time and whatever else pursuant to the
employer uh policy and practice and
procedure if the employer does not have
a procedure where they pay out sick time
that's not going to be given to them
just because it's a it's a decedent
versus a person who leaves employment
voluntarily it has to be by policy and
procedure so we would have to look at
that aspect of it and look at the
practice of that employer
but they would be considered wages so up
to the 3,000 unless the the amount is is
actually tweaked out of the bill up to
the 3,000 would be paid pursuant to
5611 which in this case if they have a
surviving spouse it usually goes to the
surviving spouse and and goes from there
um but it would include all wages
pursuant to practice and procedure of
that employer follow uh they would
include all those
unless there was no precedent or written
policy
correct well that's where when you're
having a hearing you're looking at also
past practice so if you're talking about
past practice where someone becomes uh
is no longer
alive that's going to obviously be a lot
less uh less instances that occur if
you're just talking about past practices
of when somebody leaves
an employer when and if they're getting
paid all of their vacation time a
portion of their vacation time all or
none of their sick time however that
works out you're looking at the policy
and the practice for that you're not
going to have a lot of fall back on
people who are deceased and need to have
that payment so I can see where that
would be a little bit difficult but I I
in my opinion the hearing officers and
the inspectors would be able to
administer that with without too much
difficulty
thank
you any further questions for Mr
mcra I have one it's off of what
representative Sullivan said earlier um
if direct deposit automatically finds
out that their deceased pays that all
their time puts drops it in their
checking account somebody comes along
and asks for a demand of this or we've
already paid it does this any any
protections for the employer saying hey
you know I've done all this you know not
knowing about this law we just pay them
all our stuff because they're died and
we deposited in their not countdown
record would the would the employer have
to pay a second time it's
possible I can't say that definitively
it will depend on the facts on the
record when was the employer given
notice was the employer given notice
after the payment was issued or was the
employer given notice prior to the
payment being issued um the employers
are responsible for making sure that
they understand what the current laws
are as they relate to their business and
so therefore they should know that and I
understand that this is a should but it
doesn't always happen this way they
should know that if there is a payment
that needs to go to um a deedon or a
decedent estate how that's supposed to
be handled so it really depends on the
facts that are presented it present it
depends on the evidence that's presented
as to whether or not that employer could
be subject to having to repay that
reimbursement so let's say the employe
does employee doesn't show up anymore
and it's the end of the pay period they
automatically
pay that uh employee say it's a Friday
and that you know Saturday closes the
week and they don't find out till the
following week that that employee is now
deceased and they automatically
deposited on you know midnight Saturday
so the employee doesn't have protections
prior to notification so they would have
to repay that to the air the employer
has an argument to say that they've
already made this payment they'll have a
copy of their payroll information
they'll have a copy of their stub
they'll show that the direct deposit was
made that it was processed by the bank
they'll have evidence to show that on
Friday before they had any knowledge of
the deeding
on Friday they issued payment pursuant
to New Hampshire law and then on Monday
they found out that their employee had
had died if you have someone from the
family that is disputing payment or
anything else that is in their favor for
evidence how the final ruling goes
always depends on facts but that's the
way it should be is looking at all of
the facts and the employer at that point
in time would have
that I don't want to use the word
protection but would have that ability
to defend him or herself based upon the
evidence that they present that payment
was made in good faith with no knowledge
thank you any further
questions thank you Mr mcra thank
you any more speakers on House Bill
1201 seeing none will close the hearing
dirty Mr
chairman representative solivan um it it
appears to me that uh based on the
discussion we've had so far that this uh
Bill sort of Cries Out For A
subcommittee and I would put I obviously
chairman infantine is not here but uh
perhaps the uh Deputy chair could uh
take that to the chair and see if that's
something that might
agree
e
um so I'll now open the hearing for HB
1226 and uh look to the sponsor to
present his
bill Mr chairman I am representative
Chuck Rassy from Rochester New Hampshire
and I'd like to congratulate the
chairman for and thank him for having
the only hearing I've attended this week
time I was the one that was two hours
past its scheduled time so um I'm here
to introduce 1226 FN which is uh
relative to employment protections for
freelance
employees um this is based on work that
is going around the nation right now
called the freelance uh employees
protection act uh the states of Illinois
and New York have adopted the provisions
um which some of are in this bill um New
Hampshire has a growing uh population of
freelance workers here in the state and
one of the concerns is is that there are
that people who work in the freelance
industry and I've brought somebody with
me here today who will be able to speak
much more eloquently than I'm able to
who was a freelancer for some 30 20 plus
years and um but as New Hampshire grows
and as Broadband access becomes more
prevalent in the state of New Hampshire
highspeed Broadband particularly we're
going to see more and more Freel workers
here in the state of New Hampshire what
they're looking for is certain
protections under contracts that they
expect to be paid when they when their
payments are due uh they expect certain
protections and they expect certain
requirements within their contracts uh
right now contracts tend to be all over
the place um and and many times the
provisions of contracts are not upheld
now the bill that you have before you
here I submitted late in the session I
was approached to submit this bill I'm
not a labor expert so I really didn't
know what came out of legislative
services or what was actually needed or
not I've done a little bit of work and I
think that there may be stuff that's
lacking here I worked with
representative kahill and he worked with
the Department of Labor and they saying
that some of the stuff that's in here is
already protections under the law and
that this may not be the case but I
think it's important enough because
there are so many workers in the state
of New Hampshire who are looking for
protection uh that um I would maybe not
recommend that this bill be passed this
year but that' be sent inm study so that
the legislature can get involved D in
finding a solution for these freelancer
workers uh and bring the labor
department to the table so we can work
with them to come up with a bill uh that
would meet New Hampshire's needs under
the free freelance protection act um as
I said New York and Illinois have have
submitted legisl have approved
legislation they've adopted legislation
based for these protections and we'd
like to see similar protections for the
State of New Hampshire for these
workers I'll try to answer any questions
but I've brought a young lady with me
here who can talk to you more about
freelance work in New Hampshire
very good thank you very much are there
any questions for the
sponsor representative
St um thank you for taking my question
um I am not familiar with um the term
freelance workers but I I do know about
contract workers my son for example was
a contract worker working for a video
game company and it you know was limited
to six months um what's the difference
between a freelance worker and a
contract worker I I think the pretty
much identical uh and the thing is is
this is a new section in the ordinance
this is be the new section in the rsas
dealing with contractors and and
freelance workers uh and it may be a
term that is quite similar uh but again
um Sarah can certainly uh correct me if
I'm wrong but I think there are similar
type employees um you know I at one time
years ago I was a contract work worker
for a very small time or freelancer and
sometimes um collecting your checks can
take as much time as the entire pay that
you're getting so it's a
problem was there a hand up over here
any further
questions seeing none thank you very
much for your
testimony um so next up I would like to
call Sarah Catz representing herself in
support of the bill um she has written
testimony if did you already submitted
oh yes I there I have it thank you um so
go ahead well thank you so much for
having me here today I really appreciate
this opportunity to speak with you um my
name is Sarah Catz I'm a resident of New
London New Hampshire where my mother
went to high school um I've been working
as a freelancer in the media industry
for over 20 years and the most part of
that has been in documentary television
shows um that are distributed nationally
and worldwide um for Outlets like
Netflix and A&E in National Geographic
um I have two degrees in meteor
production and I was awarded a
prestigious journalism scholarship from
the main Community Foundation where I
grew up and started my career um I want
to say that Bloomberg reports 60 million
members of the workforce freelanced in
2022 which is a huge um number of
Americans um working in that capacity
According to some statistics in 2017
12.4% of the New Hampshire Workforce um
paid self-employment taxs and there is
um some um there's some it's a little
bit vague I guess between Freelancers
and contractors I think many of those um
categories fall under the same um
working conditions and um one of the
main uh elements of that is being
responsible for your own benefits and
I'll get into that a little bit later um
and there there countless studies um
I've looked at a lot of different labor
organizations um through Academia and
there are many many studies about
increases of gig workers self-employed
freelance workers um around the country
uh the IRS also has um studies about the
numbers of freelance workers freelancing
is a broad term that refers to many
types of work across many Industries
including media web design and
accounting amongst many others um every
freelancer has one thing in common
they're expected to handle many of the
elements of work that that other people
take for granted for example they're
responsible for their own benefits their
employer does not uh pay for their
health insurance retirement overhead
vacation sick leave or parental leave
and we're not eligible for unemployment
insurance or workers
compensation the system of benefits um
such as the ones I just listed are
intended to Pro provide safety nets for
workers but that's denied to Freelancers
uh so I'm here today advocating for the
freelance protection act because anyone
who follows Trends in the economy can
see where our employment models are
heading more and more people are pushed
out of 9 to5 office or manufacturing
work and into flexible work that reaches
across several sectors labor laws have
been adjusted to keep up um with these
new new models of working and there's
also hidden cost of freelancing even
while people are um usually forced into
it freelance workers are responsible for
high self-employment taxes investing in
their own retirements extensive
Financial Accounting formation of llc's
legal legal fees marketing Tech
equipment it and overhead costs and
we're usually not trained um in
administrative skills like the ones I
just listed because our training is
really in the sector that we're um
getting hired
for so uh I really love my work a lot
I've had some really incredible
experiences working in the media and I
love my clients um but I have experience
working with certain firms who have an
understanding that hiring Freelancers is
a cost benefit to the company um and the
company doesn't have to pay o benefits
or overhead I guarantee that the tech
industry and other sectors has the same
hiring practices the cost burdens then
fall on the freelancer who's simply
trying to have regular work and regular
pay we want to earn a salary from an EXT
extremely vulnerable position in the
workforce so I'm asking the New
Hampshire house labor committee to
consider legislation to strengthen labor
protections for freelance workers the
freelance protection act was
successfully passed in Illinois New York
state New York City and Los Angeles all
Freelancers should at the very minimum
have the right to mandator mandatory
negotiable contracts be able to
negotiate a pay that's commensurate with
financial responsibilities and with
running a business they should be
guaranteed a fair process for timely
payments as we've seen from many strikes
over the last year in many Industries
like Hollywood writer strikes Writers
Guild of America Washington Post Media
news group Amazon United Auto Workers
Starbucks International Brotherhood of
electric World workers there's a sect of
our Workforce that is vulnerable to the
whims of lucrative Tech and other
sectors companies are making a huge
profit and using the hiring of freelance
workers as an excuse to deny workers
benefit the freelance workers usually do
not have a collective organization that
can represent our rights that's why I'm
asking New Hampshire house labor
committee to please reflect and enforce
labor regulations for freelance
workers thank you for your testimony are
there questions representative
thanks
for
uh I I I'm interested um and and want
you to flush out uh some things as
relates
to uh the union environment um when you
say there were no opportunities to
participate in and join some of these
other organizations to be part of them
uh what distinguishes you as a freelance
writer doing uh projects for documentary
films and other things like that what is
the distinction between you and somebody
in the guild or some other organization
uh you know that would be respon will be
getting the benefits in getting all of
these kind um a a lot of the people in
the position I'm in so I do a wide
variety of media work um and my work
isn't necessarily writing and um I'm a
member of The Producers Guild but the
producers guilt doesn't Advocate um
doesn't have any advocacy role um I'm
not I haven't been eligible to join the
other groups the writer Guild of America
um but to be frank there is a movement
towards um having more having a wider um
breadth of members of groups like the
writer guilds um but as of yet there
haven't been and um I work in
non-fiction production which is nonunion
um and it's always been non-un so the
majority of my co-workers have not been
organizations further
questions representative
BL thank you for taking my question
thank you Mr chair Mr chair um by your
description here it sounds like you know
in the uh what I've always considered a
subcontractor I'm I come from the
construction field and it sounds like an
awful would that be correct just a
subcontract environment there's there's
a number of um ways that Freelancers can
work there's many many different
contracts and I think that's one of the
things that makes it really difficult
that every contract we have is different
it's very hard to have consistency um in
income and health insurance with so many
different contracts and we often don't
have any say these contracts can often
be non-negotiable I have you know
colleagues who have had to turn down
work because they asked to negotiate the
contract and the company refused they
just said take it or leave it MH similar
similar to subcontracting thank
Selvin my observation is that you're not
really asking for much um you're asking
um for u a contract so you've got your
um the deal in writing so to speak um
and you're asking to be paid on a uh in
a timely fashion um with regard to um
the
negotiating contract of course you can
negotiate the contract but take it or
leave it is sometimes part of
negotiating um so you don't necessarily
get much there
um is there something more that you
you're looking for than what I've
described um well I think that's part of
the reason we're thinking about um
interm study um because there are many
many elements I mean working as
Freelancers in independent capacity is
very precarious um you know we don't
have vacation or sick leave um I think
that there's a lot of opportunities for
H to have stronger support I also think
there's a lot of opportunities for the
the supporting Freelancers to um help
the economy I think it would be helpful
if we didn't have to worry about
changing health insurance or you know
High self-employment taxes the the
income we get is really just our income
come but because of the way our
companies because of the way our
business operates we end up H paying
many many you know fees and having a
financial burden of operating a small
business even though all we really want
is an income and you know businesses
running a business is very complicated
and and costly so I think we're looking
for more support and more infrastructure
follow
um you your list of things that you lack
is far long than the list of things that
this bill provides U I guess is where
I'm at and um so I U I'm
not I'm not sure where the a study
committee could could take this but
idea
representative representative
C thank you Mr chairman uh thank you for
taking my question I guess to follow up
on what representative Sullivan's asking
I'm a little bit confused also as far as
what it is you're looking for on this
bill are you looking to contract in
insurance benefits and other benefits
freelancer well I I think there's room
to explore that because the financial
burden of being a contractor can be very
high and um I I think that the companies
that are Contracting us um are very
lucrative businesses and um they are I
think are well aware that they're hiring
contractors so they don't have to pay
those um Financial burdens and then it
falls on the people who are actually not
work I guess where I struggle
with capturing all of that is that a
freelancer could work for multiple
companies so which company's going to
pay the the benefits which one won't but
to me just listening to you I guess
without putting a little bit more
thought um would you maybe agree that
you're not charging enough that maybe
you need to increase your hourly rate so
that you can support your overhead costs
just like any other business would do
they have to increase their rates to
support what their overhead costs are so
is that maybe an option you should look
at well of course I think about
increasing my costs but it is a market
and um media work is actually
undervalued that it's kind of um taken
for granted the skills that often go
into media work especially now that
everyone has you know a phone on their
camera um we really get undervalued in
the marketplace very frequently um yeah
I've been asked to to do for instance
camera work um significantly below what
a skilled camera operator does it's it's
pretty common I've asked people have
asked me to do work for free um for the
they said you can do it in exchange for
exposure but exposure doesn't actually
pay my bills so you know the
I I did say no I did I don't work for
free but that it's kind of a culture in
our industry that that media work is and
the work I do is very skilled I I do
negotiate licensing contracts so I it
requires um legal skills it requires
historic research it requires technical
skills and um and it's it's just
please Representative Bob L thank you Mr
chairman thank you Miss Cass for being
here with us today um the question I
have is it looks like you're asking for
employment protections employee
protections and try to still be a
independent
contractor am I correct in
that well I guess the term is um
employment um but
it's the I mean we're Freelancers I I
we're not employees of these companies
so um I would remove the term employment
but because we're rly employed by
companies follow Mr chairman follow so
can you define the difference between a
freelancer and a staff position why
would you take a staff position so you
can get your employee protections your
health insurance and all your sick time
and everything else paid and work for
just one company or is freelancing what
you want to do and it's your choice to
do that the the industry I work in is
the jobs are are are rarely staff
positions it's not necessarily a choice
for most media workers um media workers
are are usually only offered a contract
and by staff position that would be a
long-term salary over years um including
health health insurance um retirement
paid vacation sick leave um those are
the quality categories um for a staff
person but Freelancers or independent
contractors are are rarely offered any
of those
benefits and and it's not necessarily a
choice for most media workers
thank you Mr chairman thank you further
stop thank you um as I look at this bill
there's one section of it that says
whenever a hiring party retains the
services of a freelance worker the
contract between the party and the free
um Lance worker shall be reduced oh
sorry shall be reduced to writing and
the hiring party must furnish a copy of
such written contract and um my question
there is like if I'm hiring um a
freelance photographer a freelance
photographer to um take pictures of my
daughter's wedding um typically in that
situation doesn't the um doesn't the
photographer provide the contract and
all of that stuff would the would this
bill um would this law make the burden
of providing contracts for um someone
who's going to um paint my house or um
um or take photographs at a wedding
would that put put the burden of
creating the contract on the person
doing the hiring and take it away from
the person who's providing the
service maybe this is a question for
representative
grassy I'll be happy to get back up okay
thank you I I can Envision either
parties providing a contract and
negotiating the terms of the
contract
and uh
we'll when the questions are over I will
ask you to come up and answer that I
would say I think this is the reason why
the sponsor recommended that we um study
this is It's a recognition that the
language isn't there it's more
conceptual at this point are there other
witness yeah we do we of time this a
question a little bit of unusual
question but I wonder uh this is a uh a
worker who we have not had a lot of
exposure
to um as a committee and quite frankly
the work that I've done over the years
I've had as with the aflc didn't have a
lot of Expos so it with with your
permission if if you could uh kind of
just describe what a typical week is for
a for a u somebody like yourself as so
that we have some orientation as to what
that what it's like to be a fre
freelance
sure um I mean there's there's not quite
a typical week because I do so many I
wear so many different types of hats and
I wear I do so many different types of
jobs um over the last year I think I've
had five or six contracts with um and
they've varied from um I started the
year working on a a documentary series
that was um broadcast on Netflix and I
was on a long-term contract for that
position um and it ended in March um and
following that I um I do contract work
um with the Department of State um under
a diplomatic administrative program uh
and I facilitate um foreign journalists
who travel to the US to cover American
policy so um when I wrapped my project
working on a Netflix series I um was
assigned a state department um reporting
tour and I um coordinated interviews and
travel for journalists from Indonesia um
who are covering um the energy
transition away from fossil fuels um so
I um I also did that in conjunction with
a little bit of archival research um
which is what I do a lot of where I
license media for documentaries um in
May I traveled with the journalists from
Indonesia to Pittsburgh in Washington DC
um and accompanied them on
interviews um and then I was uh
contacted to do more archival research
for um a documentary about Afghan um
women soccer team who uh escaped the
Taliban and so in July I devoted my time
to doing research for that documentary
so every job I have is different um and
every day is different if I'm not
working I'm actively looking for
work that was my my other question
relative to how you get your how you get
your work so you're you're out there
looking all the time I'm looking and
most of my work I've gotten the best
opportunities because I've been working
in the industry for 20 years and I um
get my work through my network um but it
it's taken me 20 years to kind of
network representative Cen
thank
you
so so when you are going out looking for
work um are you the one who seeking the
work selling yourself and presenting
your contract and your proposal for what
you're willing to do or are you working
more in an environment where you are
reacting and responding to somebody
else's terms and conditions and putting
your price on that and then competing
against Market other Freelancers so are
you really more responding to what we
would call a a request for proposal or
are you putting your contract and your
terms out there and selling yourself and
your skills um it's a little bit of both
um I um I don't necessarily respond to
requests for proposals but I I'm
responding for job openings with um
short-term contracts for documentary
films for instance um I do a lot of
networking um I do a lot of Outreach so
I would say it's a combination of the
two
so when you're when you're responding to
these jobs that are available and open
are you are they setting the price that
they already want to pay so you know
that going in that this is what they're
willing to pay yes and I ask for more
because I think I I recognize my value
and my experience in the workplace so I
can ask for more but that they don't you
know there's a certain expectation of
what these skills are paying so you
still have the free option of saying
okay I can't work for that money and
walking away from it
and maybe pushing the envelope making
them to make the decision to pay higher
that we don't want to Loser so we're
willing to pay higher by you walking
away I could it's it's a very
competitive field and so by saying I'm I
um this is my rate then I might walk
away and not have work for a few months
so it's it's just a bit precarious to
turn down
work thank you any further questions
representative
McKenzie
just trying to get a sense of how many
people I need a help uh how many people
do you do you get I have a sense that
are in the same kind of position uh uh
in if you have any sense of that at all
um it's it's a good question um I I've
been trying to get data that's one of
the things um this hearing happened
quite quickly in my opinion and I would
have wanted to get a lot more data um
about the number of people in New
Hampshire but I did I have seen numbers
that 12.4% of the workforce in New
Hampshire is self-employed and that
might be under reported um I suspect
there's a lot of self-employed um people
who work under these conditions in in
New
sylvestra thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question I'm still
trying to Grapple with everything you've
said um and correct me if I'm wrong
ultimately what you're looking for is
when there is a contract you want the
possible employer to have some sort of
benefits in there for you that would
what have some health benefits or or or
injury protection or whatever it may be
that's the that's your ultimate goal
legislatively for us to do that I think
legislatively for we're we this bill is
interested in in having a contract I I
don't um imagine that health benefits
will be guaranteed in the contract I
don't know that that would happen but I
think we we really insist on having an
apparatus to guarantee payments on time
and having a negotiable contract having
a contract um that we're able to
negotiate that that we don't um that has
terms I I've had contracts that required
me to work 12h hour days I've had
contracts that have required me to work
six days a week um I often have very
erratic schedules at the last minute I
easily work 70 hours a week many many
weeks of my career um so we're hoping
just to have more kind of Labor
Protections in a contract um and so we
want to negotiate the contract and and
make sure um self-employed people are
getting paid on time I haven't had much
experience with non um payment but many
many journalists I mean I'm I'm involved
in many journalism groups and there's
many media professionals and many
journalists who don't get paid on time
and they don't have an apparatus to um
enforce being paid in 30 days it takes a
lot of time um to kind of track down
payments um when they're trying to do
week any further
questions thank you very much for your
testimony thank you so much I really
appreciate your time and we did have a
question for representative grassy if
that um yeah I I think that's one of the
things I think the chairman addressed it
correctly is that we like this to go to
interim study so that we can get things
like maybe a one-day contract short-term
contracts are exempt uh and certainly
whether that contract is provided by the
uh the photographer uh it would be
something that would be you would be the
person that would be offering the
contract you just happen to be offering
his contract uh and he would sign it but
you would be the person who would be the
controlling entity as far as that that
contractor concerned it would lay out
what is specifically required of of him
to do uh usually uh when you when you do
that you you know the Contra the
photographer will say this is what I
will do and this is what you will pay
and these are what the payment
requirements are and I think that's what
this is looking for is it not only for
one-day contracts or short-term
contracts which could be Exempted from
this that people who are doing these
contracts would like to have some
protection within their contracts so
that they know when they walk into
things things aren't going to be changed
I've been meeting with these group with
a group of these people on on on Zoom uh
and most of these folks are out doing
their job not just here in New Hampshire
but all across the country and all
across the world I've had about a half a
dozen of them that we' sat down
regularly and talk to this because I was
trying to get my head around this thing
as well to say what are you looking for
what do we what do we want to do and
they're saying we'd like to have basic
requirements in our contracts we' like
have basic promises on contracts that
things don't change one of the things
that Sarah told me she says I'm out here
I'm working 60 hours and all of a sudden
you know and then that's what my
contract says that I could work 60 hours
a week and all of a sudden the contract
the person who hired me said I want more
I want you to change I want you to do
this now and I'm not going to offer you
any more money for it and so it was
basically you know if you don't like it
I'll let you out of your contract have a
good day by don't expect to get rest of
your pay and so she's sort of stuck she
gets into a contract they make a change
and then they want you to do it without
any more pay or without um you know and
if you don't like it have a good day by
I'll scrap everything you did I won't
pay you and I'll bring somebody in to
finish the job that's you know these
people would like some protections and
as you said this is something you don't
normally see here because it's not you
don't think of these people as employees
but they are and they are our residents
here in New
Hampshire and I'll be happy to answer
any
questions uh we have another question
yes representative of thank you Mr
chairman thank you again Mr grassy for
being here you just mentioned that their
employees um freelance workers that are
under contract are contracted employees
they are not not an actual employee on
staff well they're workers maybe that's
a term I should use they're workers here
in New Hampshire I just want to clarify
that thank
you any further
questions um I had some indication that
maybe the Department of Labor could
clarify some of these
uh distinctions for us in the current
you
do you want to start or should I go to a
question I say good afternoon um because
we're on a new bill my name is Tracy
mcra I'm an attorney with the Department
of Labor and the legislatively as on for
the Department of Labor uh I can
start I go ahead
okay I know this committee will ask me
whatever questions they want whatever
comes from my testimony and from
everything else so please stop me if you
need
to thank you this is not a bribe this is
for the dog okay um so we have I just I
I want to be up front and full cander we
have spoken with uh representative
grassy and we've discussed the idea of
the interim study the department of
Labor is more than willing to work with
representative grassy and see if there's
something that we can help him with this
over the summer or whatever the the
session is um and we'd be more than
happy to contribute to the um whatever
he wants to try to turn this bill into
because he's already admitted that
there's some language issues and some
questions that are coming out
obviously um
one of the first concerns that the
department had looking at this bill and
we would have to flush that out is the
actual definition of a freelance worker
um what we have here if you look at the
bill under Section Roman
4 it says that freelance worker in
quotation marks it means a natural
person or organization composed of no
more than one natural person whether or
not incorporated or employing a trade
name that is hired or retained as an
independent contractor this definitely
needs to be cleaned up because basically
what this is saying or the way I look at
this and interpret this is that a
freelance worker is an independent
contractor an independent contractor has
the freedom to negotiate their contracts
they factor in what their overheads
going to be what their inclusive of
payment of any of the employees that
they have working for them but in this
particular case it's one person so it
would be inclusive of equipment cost for
any type of benefits that they may want
for themselves and obviously you're not
going to you know have an acrel a
vacation time or sick time but at least
be able to have sufficient funds set
aside so that you can take that time for
yourself these are all able to be
negotiated into a
contract such as for an independent
contractor the same thing would be for a
subcontractor you negotiate all of that
information in as far as protections
relative to
payment the it's a contract and the way
to protect in a contract and it it can
be laborious and it can be timec
consuming is through the Superior Court
in an employment law action or a
contractual action and also keeping in
mind that superior court allows for
payment of attorney's fees uh if the
plaintiff is a provent failing party so
there is a resource for that the problem
that we also understand which is why
we're also willing to work with u
representative grassy on this to see
what we can all come up with is we also
understand that it can take a long time
to get through that superior court
process um there was a point in time
even long before the pandemic hid when
it could take anywhere from 3 to 6 years
to get a joury trial that doesn't
necessarily mean that that's what would
happen here that's the worst case
scenario um but I can see where that's a
concern when you're trying to chase your
money but the bottom line is is you're
chasing payment on a contract so there
needs to be more definitive language in
this to figure out a way to delineate
the difference if the Department of
Labor is going to be able to understand
how to interpret what the expectations
are what the wants and the needs are of
the freelance worker
community and figure out whether or not
actually the department of labor would
be able to
enforce a freelance contract if it turns
out that a freelance worker is truly
defined as an independent contractor so
under 281a which is the workers
compensation act an independent
contractor has there their definitions
first of all under
281a the presumption is that the
person's an employee unless the employer
rebuts the presumption to show that
they're an independent contractor
and they everything that miss Cat's very
uh skillfully described as to what type
of work she does what she's looking for
it fits under what an independent
contractor would be defined as
underneath um
281a and again I say as I always say it
always will depend upon the facts
presented and the evidence presented as
to whether or not someone would be
determined as such but I don't believe
Miss Catz and representative grassy are
here trying to say that a freelance
worker is an employee so I don't think
the issue would ever come to pass but
for a definition you can look at an
independent contractor in 281 A2 which
is the list of
definitions looking underneath the um
employment protections under the 275s I
27546 and maybe I get a spitball in the
back of the head if I got the name wrong
um where it talks about um independent
contractors and those definitions and
who pays for What on certain types of
issues and there may be another statute
that actually gives definitions but the
presumption under that is that they are
independent contractors unless the
person proves that they're actually an
employee
so we need to find out what exactly this
would be defined underdefined as because
if we leave it as independent
contractor then the negotiation of the
contract as much sympathy as I can
understand especially in in a in a field
where maybe higher paid parties have
more negotiating power uh than the
freelance
workers it's still a contract and
um it would be nice to have a way to
negotiate a contract better to work them
together
but we need some more work on this and
and like I said we'd be more than
willing to work with representative
grassy thank you for that explanation
that's very good
um something that comes to mind I know
we've spent a lot of time on these
different definitions of independent
contractor many on this committee are
are concerned with the issue of
misclassification and uh a lot of times
the focus seems to be that this was
presented as an independent contractor
case but it's really an employee and
when that
happens it's not a matter of negotiating
the contract that person becomes an
employee and and pay back payment of
workers comp will be due um maybe some
some benefits that were guaranteed where
I'm going with this
is wouldn't you see a concern with
defining a new class of independent
contractor or maybe not class but a a
new set of regulations on independent
contractor would interfere in ways with
that structure that has to deal with
workers comp and
misclassification and create a problem
the actual concern that actually comes
out to me is we're still calling it an
independent contractor and we already
have the laws set for that the
Department of Labor doesn't step in for
an independent
contractor um there is no payment of
wages issue for an a a single person
independent contractor the only wage
issue that comes into play with an
independent contractor or a
subcontractor is when your
subcontractor does not have workers comp
coverage
and one of the subcontractor employees
gets injured that goes up to section 18
which requires the independent
contractor or the general contractor to
pay and they of course can get
reimbursement going back for
subreg but other than that we don't deal
with independent contractors
contracts um if an issue did pop up with
respect to determining whether or not
they really were an employee versus an
independent contractor then we go
underneath the the statute and we look
and see okay this is this is what you
have to show us to determine whether or
not you're an independent or you're an
employee adding freelance as an
independent contractor I'm not sure that
it would really change anything because
it's still an independent contractor
unless we figure out something in an
interim study and work with um
representative grassy to figure out some
kind of way to look at this
differently other questions for the
Department representative
Copan thank you I guess I'm I'm
wondering based off of some of the
testimony that I heard prior to you is
um this is an almost an education piece
going back to the conversation here
regarding the definition of an
independent
contractor correct me if I'm wrong on
this but my understanding is that one of
the criteria to be an independent
contractor is that you have control over
your hours worked and that the employer
can not or the the company you're
working for cannot mandate how many
hours a day you work or what hours per
day you work that they give you the
project that needs to be done and you
get it done without the oversight and
the tight management of of the the
business that you're working
for on the surface that's that's
accurate but you can also contract in
that the independent contractor does not
work during certain hours because of
either Darkness or temperature or
there's nobody else on the job site and
then there's needs to be supervision you
can put into the contract that an
independent contractor actually needs to
work between specific hours they're able
to an independent contractor it brings
their own tools their independent
contractor holds thems out as their own
business a lot of times an independent
contractor will use their own social
security number instead of getting an F
uh Federal employer identification
number of their own but they hold
themselves out as being completely
separate from any type of employment
with that general contractor or the
hiring
party um they can work for other people
at the same time without any uh
possibility of being told you can't do
that but there can be some limitations
that are drafted into the contract
between the independent contractor and
the hiring party that does give some
specifications
if you don't like them you don't agree
to them or you renegotiate that's really
what it comes down to but some things do
need to have some kind of specification
to
them representative Balon thank you um
thank you Mr chairman and thank you Mr
mcar again um so you're saying that the
Department of Labor should have
jurisdiction over independent
contractors's contracts and have
stipulations of no contract shouldn't
shouldn't say no okay no thank you no
you can shut your microphone off now
no you're not
recognized other questions for the
Department representative
svin perhaps more of a suggestion than a
question um we're talking about an
interim study U which essentially stays
within this committee um you the study
is done by this committee um and
wondering if a more useful tool would be
an ad hoc committee um you know which
representative grassy since this is an
issue that you've bonded with um you
could figure out who you want to work
with on it and it could be people from
multiple committees people from this
committee um and uh whoever else from
the outside that you're interested in it
might be more you might get more mileage
out of that than um actually having us
form um in interim um uh uh interim
study um committee because we all know
that interim study committees frequently
nothing thank you and I will agree with
the representative that in some cases an
interim study works well with
a concept that's close but needs needs
some details on it when things are wide
open like this I my experience is it's
often better to work on the bill
proposal outside of the committee
process get something that's a lot
closer and then that gives us something
that won't just get brushed off go to
interm study and then oh we didn't get a
chance to meet uh we'll write a little
report so thank you that that is a good
recommendation question for Department
representative love
thank you for taking my question thank
you Mr chair uh Am I Wrong saying that
um subcontractor independent contractor
and freelance contractor are all one and
the same just by different
names I think that's part of what we're
trying to figure out but the way that it
appears in this particular Bill based
upon Roman 4 a freelance worker is a
independent
contractor so I think we're trying to
figure that out as far as it as it
relates to freelance worker based upon
discussions that the Department's had
with representative grassy um but an
independent contractor a subcontractor
is technically an independent contractor
to the general contractor that hired
them uh so unless we come up with a
better definition or some other way to
look at
statement further
questions
seeing none
uh that was the I don't have any other
pink cards if there's anyone else who
wanted to testify let me know otherwise
representative Kum if you could pass the
up
so uh we had two people sign in in
opposition to this bill on the blue
sheet and then online we had six names
in support and one in opposition and
with that I will close the hearing
on HB
226 and we have uh just under 10 minutes
until uh we're schedule for our next
then
e
46 and once we get the
people in who need in and out or need
will I recognize the bill sponsor
introduce uh thank you Mr chair members
of the committee I have passed around
written testimony um it is not a on the
grounds that the money that you holding
and looking at is entirely worthless it
is worth nothing you can buy nothing
with it but it is nice to have you can
show it to your friends and has a big
number on it but it is completely
incapable of purchasing anything of any
actual value and that is actually why I
brought up this bill uh this is the gold
Bill and what this bill does is it just
adds a line to the list of legal ways to
pay an employee uh who is uh either
weekly or bi-weekly
to just add gold and silver speci now it
is already currently legal to pay them
in gold and silver coins all right now
this is the legal distinction that we
probably don't run across very often in
the labor committee a coin can only be
gold and silver that is stamped by the
treasury right if it's a round made by a
private mint that's not a coin that's a
round all right and that is a legal
distinction of some importance because
you can pay someone in silver dollars
that's totally fine you cannot pay them
in in silver rounds and so that's what
this uh legislation intends to fix um
the reason for this is very simple I
don't know if you guys noticed but
there's a little bit of inflation going
on um it has the potential to go a lot
worse uh I predicted back in 2020 that
the actions of the Federal Reserve would
lead to this level of inflation and
worse I was 100% correct um and I
believe it's going to get even worse
because you just do the math on the
monetary Supply it's not a good sign
and the thing is people still need to
buy food and like engage in basic trade
and if you look at countries where the
do where their money drops out it isn't
a pretty sight people are losing weight
really fast and it's not for a good
reason is not something they want to do
and it's not something that we people in
New Hampshire should have to deal with
if it is at all avoidable and so the
reason I I I am firmly of the opinion
that the dollar is probably going to die
within the next decade or so um I could
be wrong and if I'm wrong um this bill
doesn't really hurt anybody so there's
that but the reason I say that it's
going to die soon is because of
historical precedent so I'd like to talk
about the Portuguese real uh that became
the world Reserve currency uh World
Reserve currency being a currency that
other currencies are backed in around
the year
1450 it lasted for 80 years and then it
died um it was replaced by the Spanish
reel or the Spanish dollar these are the
pieces of eight that the colonists use
it that one lasted a very long time as
far as world Reserve currencies go that
lasted about 110 years and then it died
uh the Dutch Gilder replaced it because
the Dutch were sailing a lot more than
the Spanish at that time I guess and
that one lasted about 80 years 80 years
again and then it died and that was
replaced by the French Fran that became
the world Reserve currency the currency
dour that all the other countries backed
their currency with and that one lasted
95 years and then it died and it was
replaced by the pound sterling the
British were very very smart and they
decided that what they would do is back
their money with silver uh then World
War II came along and they ran out of
silver and gold and they didn't have
anything to back it with so they started
backing with dollars uh $44 originally
and then that was drastically halfed
after a little bit and that's how the
pound sterling died and was no longer
the world Reserve currency and the US
dollar came in and uh it's been
depending on when you count it about 80
years um we're due and we had a really
good run we're due um it is very
uncommon for uh it it is unprecedent
eded for a world Reserve currency to
last more than 110 years the majority of
them last between 80 and 95 years and
then they go away but there is
currency that holds its value forever
and uh seems to be have been used for
Millennia and I have a little anecdote
for you about that so in Genesis chapter
23 Abraham buys a plot of land to bury
his wife Sarah and he plays 400 shekels
all right shekel that's silver uh that's
roughly equal to 140 troy ounces if do
the calculation because about. 35 uh uh
troy ounces equals a shekele all right
so 140 troy ounces is equal to about
$3,430 okay now the populations in Canan
at the time were a lot lower than they
are in America right now uh so if you
look at a place in America with a very
low population such as Wyoming uh you
can look online and the average cost for
an acre of land in Wyoming is
$3,434 now Abraham might not not have
been buying an exactly one acre land I
don't know if they used Acres at the
time but that's from 3,000 years ago and
that means that that silver that he was
using at that time was probably melted
down uh several times in the times you
know coming after that and it's been
traded and been in use for those
thousands of years because it's not like
silver just goes up and missing uh
people usually keep track of that sort
of thing and all the silver that we have
today all the gold that we have today a
large portion of it has been around for
hundreds of years and some of it for
thousands of years so this this bill is
essentially aimed at making sure that we
have a safety net a little bit of an
insurance policy just in case the dollar
does really go the way of the dodo um if
the dollar does not go the way of the
dodo if the dollar survives if I'm a
complete Quack and I don't have any
understanding of Economics whatsoever
then all we've managed to do by passing
this bill is made a bunch of gold bugs
and silver bugs very very happy um it
will have no negative impact on the
economy basically whatsoever because if
the dollar is around and people can get
paid in dollars people are probably
going to prefer getting paid in dollars
it's when things don't go well that this
is there for and uh with that I will uh
I will take any questions thank you for
your testimony are there questions for
the
sponsor representative B
Lon thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative grer um I like the idea
gold and silver like you said as always
holds its value to a certain extent
however um as an
employer um gold and silver values
fluctuate almost daily sometimes how do
I uh withhold a certain amount of gold
and silver that will maintain its value
for the full quarter before I send it
off to the feds or to the state or to
unemployment insurance how do I make
sure it holds its value so I'm not
asking the employee for more money at
the end of the week or I have to make up
the difference because I don't have
enough
gold on hand to pay that
bill uh so it would probably be the case
I would let the private employer sort of
figure out their own contracts uh it
doesn't really make sense for us to sort
of dictate to them how they should set
up their contracts that being said they
have an a legal obligation to pay the
IRS and so they are probably either
going to Define their contracts based on
the price of gold or they're going to so
for instance you know you get like uh
100 Cho ounces a week for instance or
they would Define their contrast based
on whatever hourly rate salary that they
normally with dollars and then merely
pay out in gold and silver um you
mentioned that the price of gold goes up
and down I would I would make the claim
that the price of silver and gold stays
roughly the same and it is the dollar
that goes up and down but that's a
matter of perspective and um the amount
that you would end up paying out that
would be up for debate and anybody who
is going to be using that early on right
so anybody who's going to be doing that
who's like oh wait it's legal to pay in
gold and or pay employees in gold and
silver now and any employee that's like
oh hey I get to be paid in gold and
silver now uh they're going to be able
to figure that out uh to the specifics
of that and when they do that if we ever
are in a situation where everybody needs
to hop on over to gold and silver
because the dollar is worthless then uh
we'll have those legal questions very
very well fleshed out um so we can leave
beginning so I do have a a followup on
that um you mentioned the the tax
implications which is where the federal
government will get involved at the
state level this is under the employee
section so things like minimum wage
other wage an hour does get the state
involved
in the state has to understand what is
the value of the money being exchanged
and does it meet the statutory
requirements so do you see any issues
with calculating whether minimum wage
has been paid calculating that sort of
thing
um at at first anybody who is going to
be taking gold and silver when the
dollar isn't completely dead yet is very
unlikely to be getting paid low enough
so that the minimum wage is of a concern
um that being said if the dollar dies
then the minimum wage is basically
meaningless with it so if you know the
Venezuelan boulevards that you're
looking at um that would probably meet
the minimum wage of Venezuela at the
time I don't know that for sure but I've
L you know if if a $500 a crisp $500
bill couldn't buy you a low of bread
then you can pay someone well above the
minimum wage and still not be paying
them very much so as far as the minimum
wage itself is concerned or other uh
labor protections I don't believe so
that it would be it would cause an
actual conflict it would be something to
figure out but at the same time I don't
believe that it would actually cause a
conflict all right thank you uh
representative bushard thank you thank
you Mr
chair um thank you for taking my
question now how would this work out
with my direct deposit if I got hey let
call that's another bill um so there's
another bill in Commerce and consumer
affairs to uh handle direct deposits um
well if you want to receive direct
deposit and the bill that's in Commerce
and Comm uh consumer affairs doesn't
pass uh then I would not recommend
taking your wages in gold and silver
just tell your employee that employer
that you don't want to do that and uh
take your wages in dollars instead
because gold is not easily sent over
wire follow up okay so would that mean
that I would not be able to pay my
income taxes well the you how am I going
to pay my income taxes with gold well
dollars okay so it's so I follow so that
means I I'd have to go through another
step so are you so you're talking about
when you're paying your income taxes
directly you're not doing withholding
from the employer side right well
wouldn't well I guess you would have to
keep money on the side to pay the IRS
okay so it's okay thank you
representative
Sullivan as I read
this um employees would have the option
of um getting a check if uh the employer
was
um paying employees in sub paragraphs B
C or
D paragraph e is the one that deals with
checks then you've got paragraph F which
is gold or silver which by my
interpretation means that an employer
could choose to pay all of his or her
employees in gold or silver whether they
like it or not and you said earlier that
PE people who um have a problem with
this would probably choose to be paid in
dollars the way this reads it's not the
employees Choice it's the employer's
choice and um now I'm going to have to
take my lump of gold and find a way to
convert it into dollars so I can can pay
my income tax and actually buy some
groceries um do you see a problem with
that I I heard that mentioned in some
newspaper uh the I I had I had a request
with OS to draft an amendment to add
explicitly if the employee likes it or
whatever and is down uh but they haven't
gotten it back to me um I don't think
it's necessary but if people think it's
necessary and they'll support the bill
if that language is in there then I
would definitely shoe hornet in because
uh I don't see any problem with amending
the bill so that it becomes more
explicit that this would have to be
voluntary on the part of the uh employee
because even though I don't believe that
it's very likely that an employer in uh
would prefer to pay an employee in a
non-inflationary currency when they can
pay them with a currency that is
inflationary um if that's a concern and
if if if if people believe that that is
a legitimate concern uh then the then I
would ask them to support the bill after
it's been amended with with the draft I
it representative kahill thank you Mr
chair and thank you representative
Granger uh if you are someone as you
appear to be who is concerned about the
dollar and and the the intrinsic value
of gold don't you have the ability to
take your $200 per term check and buy
gold with it
now you do um there are lots of costs
associated with uh purchasing gold so so
um you're going to have you're going to
be paying above spot and that's a that's
a Financial Risk that if you were an
employee you wouldn't have to be dealing
with because the because that hit would
be taken by the employer followup follow
up I'm sorry are you asking the employer
to absorb a cost in order to pay the
employees in Gold if they have to pay
for checks too it's up to the if they
want to pay the employee in gold and
they uh then yes they would have to take
the cost of purchasing the gold whatever
that may entail if they get a fancy deal
where they can get it with or can get it
uh without having to pay anything much
above the spot price and you know good
for them but um yeah the employer would
in fact have to uh pay for the means to
pay them just sort of like if you need
to pay an employee with a check you have
to buy a bunch of checks and a
printer indulge me uh since we're kind
of accustomed to either direct deposit
or or checks right now and I don't think
checks are terribly expensive is isn't
it seem kind of incredulous that we
would ask employers to go into this
Brave New Frontier and where are they
going to get the gold where are they
going to put the gold uh do they have to
have a safe or an a security guard in
order to protect their gold so that they
can make payroll well if they if they
don't want to do that then they don't
have
to I'm sure they're lining up right
thank
you representative
avalani thank you Mr chairman it's not
often that uh I have a followup when it
when this bill is this good
um the question I have is um you
mentioned that um trading gold into um
something you have to pay above spot
price or something like that um would
the seeing as the employer cannot pass
cost onto the employee relating to their
payroll acquisition whether it be
through direct deposit a hand check or
anything else they should be able to
walk into a bank and get their full
amount for as as stated on the check
could that be a issue when they go and
and have to pay a fee to get their
amount of gold back in
dollars so to make sure I understand the
question you're asking is it C can you
restate the question please so when we
pay an employee we pay them with their
fi value say he $500 a week if we give
them $500 in gold and they have to pay a
$25 fee to convert that into dollars and
they only get $475 back will the
employee be on the hook for that $25
because now they no longer have $500 in
Gold would the employer be on the hook
for that because there's a fee
follow Rae associated with cashing that
gold in I I don't believe so um I I
no if this bill passed I don't see how
that would be the case
no representative stop thank
you um
uh right now an ounce of gold is worth
about
$2,000 and gold is pretty heavy and I'm
not quite sure how large an ounce is um
if you owed somebody
$50 how would you pay them in Gold that
is such a good question I would like to
introduce to you a gold
back so this is a $5 gold back note it
is about the size of a paper dollar you
can fold it everything like that and it
is one 200th of a troy ounce um this is
a single New Hampshire gold back and it
is 1/ 1000th of a troy ounce this is
worth about
$423 so you could use Gold bags for such
purposes if you so
choose any other
questions oh we do have one
representative thank you again and and
thank you for the indigence
representative Granger um is there a
cost for trading in a gold back at the
bank
I I don't believe most banks deal with
goldbacks they do or they don't I I do
not believe that most banks do um if you
go to a coin dealer or something like
that usually the markup is 100% above
spot roughly about 100% thank
you representative
Kum thank you Mr chair thank you
representative grer for this uh last
session I believe we had a bill in front
of us regarding paying employees with an
ATM card were you in favor of that bill
uh I was kind of not in favor of that
bill mostly because it seemed as though
it I don't want to go off into the Weeds
on that bill but it seemed to me as
though see I don't want to say anything
bad about people who come here or
testify or any I'd rather not answer
that question but I did oppose that bill
I guess so I guess I am answering it but
I don't want to go into the Weeds about
why follow up follow
up do you remember if there was a lot of
com ation and concern over how the
employee would be able to get paid and
whether there would be fees associated
with that ATM card uh yes thank
you any further
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank you have several cards
on this and uh first up I am thinking
leave the department to the end to
answer all questions so first up I'd
like to call Kate Horan representing the
New Hampshire Association of counties
she is speaking in opposition to the
bill is handing out some written
testimony and we'll speak for two
minutes yes thank you Mr chairman it's a
pleasure to be in front of this
committee twice in one day uh the
association is opposed to House Bill
1246 uh just to remind everyone the
association represents all 10 counties
with all of your elected and appointed
officials uh your county administrators
are extremely concerned about how this
would be implemented
they uh in addition to the questions
about price fluctuation and does the
price count when I'm running payroll
does the price count when that employee
comes to pick up their gold or silver
there's also no requirement for the
employee to say I want to be paid in
gold and silver this week so it is our
administrator's opinions that they would
have to have gold and silver for every
single employees paycheck at the County
facility which would mean additional
safe security um and additional costs we
would also need additional staff hired
at each County to do the conversion rate
um so long story short they anticipate
several increased costs associated with
this bill and obviously there is no
funding mechanism from the state to help
us Implement that um I am happy to
conclude my testimony there but can take
any questions to the best of my
ability thank you I do have a question
if I understood what the sponsor
presented um
and some of the points made about maybe
it it's not organized the way it should
be um but I understood his intent is
that a an employer could offer this or
not and um wouldn't it be the case that
that the counties would not want to
offer it and simply wouldn't rather than
in Cur cost uh thank you for the
question Mr chairman I think we would
want some clarifying language into the
statute around that because there
obviously is some confusion the way our
administrators read it it is the
employees Cho Choice as to whether how
they are paid all right thank you
further
questions seeing none thank you very
much for your
testimony um next I would like to call
Representative belshire uh I he is a
co-sponsor of the bill and we'll speak
for three
minutes thank you Mr chair and members
of the committee uh it's nice to be here
before you for the first time in this
committee so I'm going to try not to Bel
labor points that have already been made
I'd like to take this in a little bit of
a different direction because
frankly I don't see this as being
something that's going to happen right
now I'm not talking about this bill I'm
talking about anybody electing both
employer and employee electing to be
paid in gold and silver it doesn't make
sense under our current circumstances
okay let me get that out right
now
however it is I think this may have
mentioned earlier it is possible perhaps
even probable that America is going to
lose Reserve currency status at some
point in the coming years or
so if that happens we are highly likely
to experience a hyperinflationary
environment
such environments have happened before
in history all we have to do is look at
a famous example the Yar Republic what
happened when the Yar Republic there
Deutch Mark began skyrocketing in um
relative uh disv
valuation all of a sudden you would go I
used to hear stories that people in uh
in Yar Germany at the time would order
their coffees two at a time
because you sit down by the time you've
drank the first one the price has
doubled the thing is that is a threat
that we're facing as a possibility not
necessarily even a probability but it is
a
possibility and if we were to put this
in law and the way that I read this is
it would require the ascent of both the
employee and the employer to want to go
about
this it would put something in
place that would be already existing
because we all know that the speed of
this legislature is nothing compared to
the speed of
hyperinflation so that's a very real
threat that we could face and when such
a thing happens it's not as though um
it's not as though people are going to
receive a their payment in gold and go
some bank somewhere and turn that gold
in for Dollar Cash and then go buy stuff
with cash that's not what happens if you
look at the Historical reality of what
occurs in a hyperinflationary
environment is people turn to things
that have a store of value and they
don't just get paid in it they trade in
it they buy things with gold and silver
this happened in wmart Germany most
recently this happened in Venezuela just
a few years back it's a very real
phenomena so it's not it's not a matter
of having to worry about the relative
tradein values because people aren't
going to be buying stuff in dollars if
that were to happen now the other thing
I would say is there is a second
scenario under which something like this
would be very valuable all across the
world right now in fact Davos is meeting
at this moment among their agenda items
is something that's been going on all
over the world to include America the
Federal Reserve and the European Union
they're talking about Central Bank
digital currencies now multiple
presidential candidates have worned
about warned about the threat that these
could pose now if they were done in the
correct way which would be a freedom
loving kind of way they could be very
useful tools but what we've learned so
far including from quotes from Jerome
Powell is these that what is being
designed right now and being piloted by
the New York Federal Reserve is not a
privacy respecting thing it is something
that will if implemented give government
the ability to stop transactions at
will and we need to be able to provide
our people with the ability to continue
on with their daily lives in the event
that the dollar would be phased out in
favor of a central bank digital currency
that was in a very bad way and that's
certainly not a pie in the sky kind of
thing because I can think of at least
what two or three times in the history
of America where the currency has been
phased out for a new one so this this
happens every once in a while and we
might be coming up on another one very
soon and with that I'm happy to take
questions thank you for your testimony
questions seeing none thank you again
for your
testimony um next up I would would like
to call Katherine heck who is
representing New Hampshire Municipal
Association and speaking in opposition
minutes good evening Miss good evening
my goodness I don't know where I am good
afternoon Mr chairman and members of the
committee for the record my name is
Katherine heck and I represent the New
Hampshire Municipal Association in 234
cities in towns in New Hampshire um I
don't try not to belabor but just add to
prior testimony that we are opposed to
this bill because we share concerns on
how we would implement this bill and do
so cost effectively as a stewards of
public funds tax dollars we are really
not in the position to be in the
Commodities Market where I started my
career on Wall Street um so I will say
that under current federal law 31 us
code 513 legal tender silver and gold
that are not minted by the US Treasury
um are not recognized as payment for
debts or recognized in federally
chartered Banks so they will not conduct
transactions in that commodity so to
answer your question you cannot bring
this to any ferally Chartered bank and
trade it um the United States versus car
um the ninth Circuit Court ruled in 2013
that payroll taxes and how they must be
assessed would be calculated on the fair
market value at the time of the
transaction as taxable property so why
we would not have any additional payroll
tax here in New Hampshire on silver and
gold certainly the IRS would
now because of that subsequent law there
have been IRS guidelines um issued based
on how you would calculate that and when
and you are subject to audit if you are
transacting in silver and gold to make
sure it's the timing that agrees with
the IRS standards for paying those
payroll taxes when the commodity was
traded so I think it opens up um a
myriad of concerns that we would have in
trying to implement this I would
certainly defer to the Department of
Labor to um discuss whether or not this
is is a mandate on the employer to pay
if the employee asks or whether it's
mutual or whether it's up to the
employer but RSA 4129 does require that
we have internal controls around and we
Safeguard all of our funds so in
addition to physical concerns around
this commodity we would also have um
concerns around how we would deposit how
we would trade where we would trade um
as we talked about this is traded on the
OTC in London the US futures the comx
market and High Gold Exchange and I did
pull up what gold was trading at today
because that's fun it is um trading at
$214 per ounce up1 n% from yesterday's
price of $210 compared to last week
Gold's down
88.5% and a 52- we high is
2,121 a 52 we low is
1,982 so I guess to most simply equate
how we would do as the government
Finance adviser the accounting around
these dollars that is one of my main
roles is we would be having and
employers as well it would be much like
when you do foreign exchange
transactions when you travel that's how
we would be trying to calculate these
transactions and our concern is we are
not in the business of ever losing or
having a decreased value tax dollar we
really need dollar for dollar so in
looking at one of the examples presented
if I paid an employee $500 in gold at
that value at that time and everything
worked with the IRS and it was fine then
they would have I had to buy that buy
that amount so maybe it cost me
$525 for that $500 worth of gold and
then when the employee goes to use it to
buy groceries pay bills or whatever the
case maybe they have to go to a a I
guess right now there's gold coin
dealers pawn shops they have to go
somewhere else to transact that so we're
really devaluing twice that the value of
the US dollar and I do understand some
of the concerns presented around the
value of of the dollar but we did
decouple many years ago right we
decoupled from the gold standard so we
share we are concerned we share some
similar concerns as the counties and I'm
certainly happy to take any questions
thank you for your testimony are there
questions representative kahill thank
you Mr chair and thank you Miss HEC uh
is it safe to assume that you didn't
injure your wrist by lifting your
paycheck
yes yes sir thank
you any other questions representative
balani uh thank you Mr chairman and
thank you for the question M organ um
I'm Sorry Miss heck my apologies
um so similar question $500 um employer
has to pay uh employee needs to be able
to take their check to the bank and have
no fees on cashing their check there
would be a fee related to cashing
through gold at a supplement
supplementary banking
institution um would the employer be
responsible for that fee I have not
found any case law to either affirm or
dispute that claim so I do believe once
the transaction has been completed the
employee would be responsible for how
I'm interpreting it because it trans you
know the employer made the employee
whole but I think it could be for
interpretation when I bought the gold
I'd have to have extra stores on hand
because they fluctuate in price I don't
know how I'm paying 89 cents if the gold
back is worth some other amount although
I am a town Treasurer and I do look
forward to desk fulls of gold no I'm
just kidding I'm just teasing I
shouldn't have said that um it is an
interesting concept though so I we are
concerned though that it really does
devalue if I had to go and gold happen
to be traded low that day and I have to
go I mean I live in a very small town I
might have to travel 20 or 50 miles to
get that gold I'd have to do it on a
convenient day to make sure it's open
it's secure and then by the time I pay
the employee that gold could be higher
or lower in value and then by the time
the employee goes to trade it back it
could be higher or lower in value and
that that is a real concern depending on
the market um and Market volatility
thank you and and I should add that
there is there is a fee associated with
these transactions because these are
private businesses dealing in silver and
gold currently there's not a banking
institution where you give a dollar and
you get a dollar or you give a
papercheck for a dollar you get a dollar
back there is um a premium paid for
these
transactions thank
you any other
questions seeing none thank you up thank
you and last up I have the a card from
Tracy mcrath from the Department of
Labor um
testimony all right good afternoon my
name is Tracy McGraw I'm an attorney in
Le legislative leaon with the Department
of Labor and thank you for giving me the
opportunity to answer some of the qu
there were an abundance of questions so
I'm going to ask you to repeat some of
the questions that you want to but I'll
do the best that I can to remember some
of this um one of the issues I did want
to point out was cost of the
employee section 27543 specifically
states in the first paragraph that to be
able to use the money that's being paid
for wages it has to be at a cost no cost
cost to the employee so that takes care
of that problem um whether the employer
chooses to Bear those costs that's going
to be up to the employer but the statute
already protects the employee from
having to pay that there was another
issue as far as the um arrangement of
bcde and F in this particular issue the
way the department would
interpret
27543 is
number one would be payment in lawful
money of the United States
so it'll be interesting after the
discussions today and after what
representative Granger is is discussing
and and mentioning in his bill lawful
money at this point in time is
Cash um and so that's option A and then
we go into the other options option b is
electronic fund transfer option C is
direct deposit with written
authorization from the employee option D
is the payroll
card currently option e
says that if your employer if you don't
want B C or D you can ask your employer
to pay by check at a local bank local to
the business so that the employee if
they have to go to the business it is a
local location for that um we recently
had a situation where someone had a bank
in in Seattle was not local here but the
business was actually local here that
had to be
fixed don't
ask um so just as housekeeping only
switching and putting gold and silver
after d as e so to speak taking current
e and bumping it out to F would then
give the employee the option of any of
of those B CDE e being gold and
silver cash and then the last one F
being check on a local institution at no
cost to the
employee so that might help with a
little bit of
housekeeping
um the Department of Labor has some
concerns with respect to how to address
some of the issues involved here uh we
talked about the value of gold I pulled
up one I know that representative stab
said something about it um the value of
gold it does change so if an employee is
paid at 5 o' and they agree at 5 o'clock
that the value of their paycheck is $500
and they're handed something that is the
equivalent of $500 in
Gold what if on Monday that $500 is now
worth $ 250 can they come back in for a
wage claim with the employer and say you
owe me another
$250 we don't know the answer to that
question but it definitely poses a
problem and it's definitely going to
come to the Department of
Labor the reverse is the same will the
employer be able to ask for
reimbursement of pay if the person was
overpaid because on Monday his his pay
is now worth $1,000 instead of the 500
to which he was actually owed so that's
a concern that we have
um the issues I I believe the the last
speaker U Miss HEC testified to the US
statute which talks about that what
legal tender is is that which is
produced by the Federal Reserve based
upon the uh us code at least as it is
currently it's unclear whether
representative Granger wants to turn
gold and silver to be legal tender which
is unclear also whether or not a
constitutional amendment needs to be
done to do that
or if this is just gold and silver is
gold and silver
and I I don't know what legal tender in
the minds of those that are exchanging
it um one of the things that
representative Granger brought up that
it brings up the concern about
valuation was that gold back which I'd
never seen
before but when asked the value or when
spoken the value he said I may have the
numbers wrong but the the word was right
about
$423 so how is about going to be
exchanged and done in an accurate Manner
and that's a concern this is this is not
a this is not a criticism these are
concerns that we would have to deal with
when we're talking about wages when
we're talking about the calculation of
average weekly wages for workers comp
cases when we're talking about wages for
a wage in hour case where an employee is
looking to be reimbursed for wages that
they believe that they're
owed and that's that's what I'm looking
at here this is this is not any type of
a negative or derogatory comment being
made but these are the concerns that we
have on how we can enforce this and how
can we do this in a fair way that's
going to be acceptable to everyone in in
the picture
um why don't you ask me some of the
other questions that you had because I
have a page of notes here that's all
over the place all right I would like to
ask you a question that kind of strings
together some of the things you said and
hopefully it will come off in the way
that I intend it because it's not
supposed to be complicated so um right
now and if if we we don't change the law
If an employer and employee agreed to
pay tied to
a wage tied to a commodity so let's say
I'm in the logging business and so I say
I'm going to pay you you know X the
value of on Friday I'm going to give you
the X amount of whatever the lumber
price is could I
legally agree to that under employment
law or does that go back to this issue
of legal tender and the Department's
going to require that at some point that
be reduced to a dollar figure
that then can
be work with I think I understand what
you're asking I do okay so and I think
that also goes back to the definition
that was given for legal tender for um
the US code which clearly says United
States Coins and currency so we're
talking about coins and currency that
are produced by the US by the treasury
um including Federal Reserve notes and
circulating notes of Federal Reserve
Banks and National Banks are legal
tender for all debts public charges
taxes and
dues I guess the question could be is is
Wages included in that but looking at
the the overall picture of what is
included wages would be included because
they are required to be
paid um so at this point in time the
United States does not the federal
government does not look at gold and
silver except for gold and silver coins
that are marked with a valuation and are
produced by our treasury uh did the
United States does not look at pieces of
gold gold leaf um and I did look that up
and it is still not accepted as as
tender thank you to my Deputy
Commissioner
um that at this point in time it would
not be accepted for that so I think that
there would be an issue whether or not
that issue would come to fruition at the
department versus Superior Court I don't
know the answer to that
question um but I think that as far
to you would have to you would have to
have okay I I I'm not allowed to give my
opinion so based upon what I understand
with the Department of Labor how it
would be interpreted if it is not legal
tender it is going to be extremely
difficult
to be able to process claims pay claims
order claims to be paid and to enforce
the judgments that are handed down and
at this point in time it is not legal
tender all right thank you other
questions for the
Department representative
bani uh thank you Mr chairman thank you
again M mcra you've had a long day with
us um so could we further Define um the
cost of gold and silver I know we're
talking about legal tender but if this
is between an employee and an employer
could could there be definitions of okay
at Friday um of the pay period at 5:00
pm whatever the amount of gold is worth
is what you're going to be getting paid
could that be part of the restructuring
of or if we if you redefined it as e
could there be some caveats in there
that will further Define the cost of the
cost and expectations of the gold
we all know that people can contract any
way they want to when it comes to the
payment of wages though when it comes to
the payment of a debt and in this
particular case you have an employee who
has performed a job and the debt that is
owed is by the employer to the employee
to pay their earnings it has to be in
legal
tender which was kind of my question too
but
hiss it a lot simpler than than my bir
are there other
questions seeing none thank you very
much for your input and as I said that
was the last card that I had um if you
could pass that up um we are running a
little bit behind my apologies but I
think representative McKenzie is going
now
so we had one sign in against that bill
and then online we had two sign in in
support and one in
opposition so with that um I would like
to
close uh HB
1246 and open our final bill of the day
HB 1315 and recognize the prime sponsor
chairman
you my name is Mark McKenzie and I'm a
representative from District 40 in
Manchester and um I this particular
piece of legislation I was too late to
get it pulled and so it came before this
committee as it has to under the rules
but I would ask uh that this committee
um vote this inexpedient legislate and
we send it on the consent calendar down
to the floor
um so if you if you could do that that'd
be fine Mr
chairman all right thank you very much
any questions for the
sponsor you uh actually representative
avalani would like to ask you something
bill
thank you Mr chairman thank you rep
representative McKenzie um why did we
bring this
up and why do you want to dispose of it
uh there was an issue that uh I had
hoped to flush out prior to this uh
hearing and I wasn't able to do that and
so I'm not prepared to defend it this
legislation at this point so thank you
thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative thank you any other
questions seeing none thank you very
much um is there anyone else who wants
bill all right I I don't think
that's uh so seeing none
but I will close the hearing on HB
um
all right so uh is there any other
business to be discussed for the
committee all right seeing none I don't
know if we even need that but thank you
very much for uh all your participation
[Laughter]
adjourned